Oh
yes,
we live Tommy buttons.
Let's do it.
Dude.
Did you,
um,
did you go to the comedy store at all
yesterday?
Yesterday?
No,
I'm going tonight is heavy,
heavy,
heavy.
Yeah.
I imagine it would have it the day after
Mitzi died.
The clothes,
the comedy store down on Wednesday and
yesterday was the first day it was open.
It was heavy.
Imagine this the first time it's been
closed in a law.
Like they never close.
I can't remember the last time it was
closed.
It was heavy.
You could just feel it in the air.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I felt it was everybody talking about
it,
but it was bombing to really.
Not on my show wasn't too bad,
but the o man,
it was thick.
Know boy is in the air,
you know,
that's real sadness.
Oh yeah.
Paul was.
I've never seen he cry.
He was there.
Yeah.
He was crying in the onstage.
No,
he didn't go on stage.
She's not going to go on stage for a
while.
I wouldn't have gone onstage if I wasn't
getting ready for the special.
I would have definitely taken the night
off.
Yeah,
if I could have,
you know,
if it wasn't early,
if people aren't,
are going to see it,
it just felt I didn't feel silly,
you know what I mean?
I like to feel silly,
feel loose,
loose in a good mood,
happy.
Everybody felt vulnerable.
Everybody felt,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know all the people in the world
that are not comedians.
She's into the number one most important
figure in all of comedy.
That wasn't a comedian.
And then even when you say the ones that
were comedians,
damn,
she's in the running for number one.
Even with the comedians.
I know
she shaped so many,
you know,
she built that whole,
that place and,
and,
and she,
she,
you know,
they call her godmother,
but it really was like that because she
advised so many people.
And actually here's the thing,
a lot of people have advice for you,
but she was giving good advice to
people.
I mean,
look how many people hire.
Hold her in that regard.
Yeah.
You know,
legendary people are like,
she's it man.
Universally.
Yeah.
There's no one going.
Mitzi shore ain't shit.
No,
nobody says that unless you didn't pass
you.
Yeah.
Like me,
I met her once and she was like,
no thanks.
But what year was this?
2,000.
Six or seven.
Oh yeah,
I remember.
Well,
here's the thing,
when I met her,
she was um,
she was already like,
it was at the end of when she would be
at the store.
She was,
she was not 100 percent doing well.
No,
she was rough around then when you would
see her,
she'd be shaking.
It would be very hard.
Yeah.
I just,
you know,
when someone's gone,
you stop and think about those times
when you were around them.
You just like,
I wish I took it in and realize more
that she wasn't.
She wasn't going to be there one day,
you know?
Did you guys have a good relationship?
Yeah,
we did.
I mean,
up until the seven years that I wasn't
there.
And even then it was never her fault.
I called her the date.
That whole Mensa thing broke out.
I called her up and told her everything.
I told her the guy's been stealing
material and the whole deal.
And every comedian feels so
uncomfortable working around them that
they flashed a light whenever he's in
the room so that no one does their
material.
And you just start working the crowd.
I go,
it's a fucking war zone there.
It's terrible.
And her exact words.
Well,
while Jess Day away from,
um,
what time you want to go up tonight
knows it.
Yeah.
And I,
I said,
and whenever you want to put me up,
she gave me a spot.
And then the comedy store called me an
hour,
two hours later,
whatever it was.
Instead I was banned.
And that's how I go.
What the fuck are you talking about?
I just got off the phone with Mitzi.
She gave me a 10:00
spot.
They're like,
well,
Muzzi wasn't aware of everything that
was happening.
I got the fuck she wasn't.
I told her,
I told her everything.
I go,
who's running the store now?
You,
you run running the store and the fuck
Outta here.
I'm not working for you.
And you guys are going to ban me because
I added a joke.
Thief like this is you guys sell art.
You gotta a thief of art that's in your
midst.
You did you understand that?
What a big deal that is,
someone is making millions of dollars of
stealing other people's ideas and you
guys are just going to let it go because
he sells tickets.
The Fuck Outta here,
but my cora was never with her.
I was with the other guys.
Did you guys speak after that happened
to?
He never spoke to her again.
Wow.
I said,
yeah,
well by the time I came back she was
real rough,
real rough.
You know,
she had other things to worry about.
Of course.
I just had one.
I had that one showcase.
Those.
My only direct experience with her when
I met her in 1994.
She gave me a lot of good advice.
She did.
She.
She always gave me good spots,
like hard fucking spots,
always after dice after Martin Lawrence
after if anybody would crush,
I'd gone after him after Chris Rock,
after this guy,
after that guy anyway that would crush
she.
She liked you.
She would give you the.
The deaths spots really well,
which you realized that you have to.
You gotta eat shit,
man.
You got to develop.
You can't just have.
It's like there's an analogy with
fighting like you can't just fight
people that you could beat the shit out
of.
You have to fight people that are going
to test you.
Sure,
because otherwise you're going to
develop like a,
an unrealistic sense of your abilities
and an unrealistic sense of other
people's abilities and you have to.
You have to.
You have to feel what it's like.
I think as an up and comic comic,
like you start thinking you're pretty
good and then you have to see someone
who's really good and then you go,
oh my God,
I'm terrible.
Yeah,
and then you go on after them and that
feeling of just total ineptitude or you
just feel so shitty and clunky and
awful.
You have to feel that too.
Just it's.
That's the number one motive,
like bombing is one of the best things
that can happen to a comedian.
That feeling of following someone great
is basically.
It almost feels like shame,
shame,
shame.
Like someone goes,
Hey,
do you want to feel humiliated?
Like it's fucking shame,
man.
Yeah,
I see it all the time too.
I watched it the other day at the
Improv.
I watched somebody bomb.
They went on after somebody's crushed
and they just would just choking like
right away and you just go,
woof.
You got to reexamine.
Yeah,
but it's a gift.
It really is.
It helps you in those moments are gifts.
Those moments of failure are gifts.
They just feel like shit at the time,
but you got to realize that that like
every like leap that I've made in my act
in or in my,
you know,
my,
my career as a comedian has come from a
humiliation,
like you hit that humiliation,
they go fuck.
Then he come back strong in that.
That's what everything else to totally.
Because as long as you actually think
about it and try to address it.
Yeah,
because it is a,
it's devastating.
It's only not helpful if you go,
well,
I'm just not going to even put any
thought into that experience at all guys
do do that.
Of course they did lock it out,
block it out,
block everything out,
and they never go anywhere and they're
still doing the same 15.
Yeah.
It's a defense mechanism.
You get just get scared and you can sort
of just autopilot your way through some
half ass bullshit.
Meanwhile you're about to go.
Do you have a weak man one week from
today,
son?
I'm ready.
I'm excited that I'm doing it in a cycle
around when you're doing it,
you know,
like you just did yours and then you
know,
there's a couple other guys.
Joe Is getting ready to do one.
Everybody's Kinda getting ready to.
Joey lined up for one.
She always got something cooking.
We're trying to figure out what's
happened and either he's going to do
something with Netflix or I'm going to
direct it and then if,
if Netflix doesn't do anything with
them,
I'm just going to find out something and
that's enough.
Just we're going to take over the ice
house for three days.
That's just fucking go bananas.
Just let him go.
He's on fire right now.
Yeah.
He lost a ton of weight now.
I haven't seen him and I'm like,
I don't know,
a month ago or so last night I was like,
Holy Shit Dude.
He's like,
I'm down 30 pounds.
So when Shit,
you could tell he's.
It's weightwatchers taking my vitamins.
Counting points.
Yeah.
Those eggs.
Zero points for Exxon.
He only eats the yoke.
He cuts.
So you see them cut the egg white out.
You're like,
oh yeah,
egg whites.
He's like,
throws it off the plate.
yolks.
Wait,
everybody eats the egg.
White was like,
that's for pussies jokes.
They don't do that anymore.
You know that egg white thing is
bullshit.
They realized that most of the protein
and.
Well,
the whole idea was about.
It's just,
it's hard to shake off old ideas when it
comes to nutrition and the old idea was
that dietary cholesterol is bad for you,
but it's not right.
Dietary cholesterol is actually good for
you.
It sounds crazy to hear it.
And also,
by the way,
I mean,
I know this sounds like a real simpleton
thing to say,
but how do they get this shit wrong for
so long?
You know?
Good.
It's a good question.
All we here for years and years is this
is doctors are telling you to do this
and then it feels like one day like,
oh,
we got all that shit wrong.
What?
You can use someone like Chris crusher
or Dr Rhonda Patrick,
or like Robb Wolf,
like real nutrition experts that really
understand the way nutrients like the
way your body absorbs them and what's
what's necessary,
what's not necessary.
What they're finding out is that first
of all,
there was,
you know about the whole thing where the
sugar industry paid off scientist to say
that saturated fat was the cause of
heart disease.
No,
he didn't know about that.
Oh my God.
I was in the New York Times.
It was crazy.
In 19 fifties.
Sugar Industry paid off scientists to
take the blame away from sugar and put
it on saturated fat.
I know the sugar lobby is insanity and
that that's the only thing we haven't
seen on the percentages of,
of daily value is the percentage of that
sugar you're supposed to have.
Yeah.
In other words,
when you see like,
you know,
presenting.
Yeah.
And then what percentage of and then
sugar,
it'll be like 52 grams percentage
nonexistent.
So yeah,
they fucked everybody up because they
got everybody thinking that it was
saturated fat.
That was a problem.
And it's really a refined carbohydrates,
bread,
pasta.
Your body converts that into sugar and
then sugar itself.
So there was that,
there was,
you know that.
And then there's also,
there's a reality of refined
carbohydrates mixed with saturated fat.
It's not a good combination.
When you mix the two of them together,
it is not good for you.
Especially for some people,
you know,
different people's body bodies absorb it
differently.
But when you're on a high fat,
low carb diet,
it's very important that you,
that's how you do it.
You can cut that out.
You don't want to go high fat and
refined carbohydrates and sugars as
well.
It's not good for you.
And that that is like a.
So there's a mechanism to it that Dr
Rhonda Patrick explained.
But essentially it's just terrible for
you.
Yeah.
If I have,
I have high fat and if I go one week
just not even go crazy.
But just like,
yeah,
I'll have bread with this and like that,
like in three days I'll weigh eight
pounds more.
It's crazy and I just go,
I can't do that.
It's crazy how the weight just piles on
you.
Yeah.
It's bananas.
Speaking to wait bird specialist also
coming out.
Speaking a way.
Yeah,
it's coming out.
I think.
What does it have to do with weight?
I was just saying births fast.
I was just kidding.
I was just associating words,
attitude that.
But I think it's considered a Hashtag.
Hashtag Bert is enormous.
Uh,
it's great.
I love that.
He's also shirtless in this one.
He took his shirt off and special.
Well,
at least you'd be able to see the
background being different.
It's true.
He's so crazy.
Um,
but yeah,
that was coming out.
Netflix this summer I think.
Does he just always take your shirt off
now?
I don't know.
I think on,
I think when it's a big,
like a.
If he's doing his weekend,
it's big shows.
Yes.
What is that?
I think he's doing spots.
He doesn't necessarily do it.
What is it,
Jamie?
Just put up the pool.
What is wrong with your microphone?
Yeah.
Fix that son.
He uh oh.
Oh my goodness.
He's swimming.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're watching them swim.
Why are you showing us this champion?
Just to fuck is wrong with you.
Jamie just follows everything burt does.
He does?
Yeah.
He's a disciple.
He's a machinist.
He's.
Oh,
that's a.
They called them that.
Fix your mic pro.
You're a.
you're an audio engineer.
Fix your mic.
That was fucked up yesterday too.
You might need a new mic.
I got some backup links I can drive
over.
Yeah.
I mean your mom's house right down the
street.
Right down the street about now.
Try it.
Nothing.
I don't hear God damn nothing.
Oh.
Hey.
There's still a little crackly.
No.
Yeah,
I think it's actually a fader.
there's something wrong with that.
Oh Shit.
Jesus.
The problems.
So we were talking before the show about
you doing a whole new hour now.
How long did it take you to concoct a
whole new hour?
Well,
I mean it's definitely still building,
you know,
it's new,
it's new.
And I,
and I know,
I'm like,
I know it's 15 away from being something
where I'm like,
oh,
this is a solid,
you know,
70 minute show,
which is what,
how I liked to do a theater,
so it's going to be months still,
but it's,
I did an hour at the tabernacle last
week of,
of uh,
it's all new and I did 10 that I didn't,
that I did before that I didn't put it
in my special.
So it's like,
that's mine to manipulate.
Nice.
I mean,
it was,
I've been working on it for I guess
since December.
No,
you know,
like,
around then December,
January.
Yeah.
So four months,
five months.
Um,
it was a blast.
That was one of the most.
It was so much fun because I had so much
anxiety going into it.
Oh yeah.
Because it was the first big show of
new.
I've been doing some club weekends and
you know,
clubs are just different.
They're just different and you can get
away with more,
you can get away with more and you're
more exposed in a big room.
Oh yeah.
So I was like,
I mean,
the night before I was like,
what if none of this works like that,
that kind of feeling,
or I was like,
what am I doing?
And uh,
you know,
I woke up early that morning and I was
just like,
Nah,
it'll be all right now.
You got to be fun now.
It's going to be fucking terrible.
Like I was going,
I was going back and forth like that on
that show,
but it ended up being just utter chaos.
I mean,
they were just,
they were all about it.
So it was really fun.
I mean I just,
it was,
it was so much more fun because I had
that feeling of uncertainty of course.
So that's one of the cool things about
doing a special is that like you,
you get so introspective,
you examine every bid with a microscope,
you go over it with a fine tooth comb
for like weeks before you shoot.
Yeah.
You start second guessing everything.
And then that week of,
and that,
you know,
on the last one I did in Denver,
I did a show Wednesday and Thursday I
did Oakland.
And then Friday I came into Denver,
I did a midnight show at the works
downtown and every show is different and
you're like,
this is terrible.
But then you know,
and then you have those two tapings.
And I think every.
This.
I did my,
that was my third,
uh,
I think our one and you know,
I think almost all three.
The first taping is over and you're like
this good.
That's fine.
We could use it.
And then every time.
The second one is just
loops.
Yeah.
Once you get it into camp,
that's why I decided to do for.
That's smart.
Yeah.
Because I feel like you do four and then
one of them's going to be like a real
show.
True.
Yeah.
And the thought,
what I've found out,
what I've found out though is if I have
for the first one,
turns out to be a real show because
you're not as.
Not as under as much pressure.
Right?
Because if you have to,
you have two barrels,
like you get the one done and then you,
you feel like,
oh,
I got it now.
It can be loose for the second one,
but if you have four,
you feel like,
Eh,
let's see what happens with this one.
And you could at least that's how San
Francisco was when I did.
Um,
uh,
the fillmore.
That's a good spy.
That's great spot.
But it's a high ceiling.
I'm really excited about the Wilbert.
Wilbert is kind of a high ceiling too.
But the,
Wilbur,
I liked the wilburn.
Each place has a low ceiling was three
stacks of people and then like you have
a high ceiling and there's a high
ceiling and Bong amongst the,
a above the front people in the very
front row.
But it's basically the three,
300 seat comedy clubs stacked on top of
each other.
That's what it's like.
Such a great room.
Fucking amazing.
I think I'm,
I'm,
I'm looking.
I mean,
you know,
my,
my next one will be a while from now,
but I've already started talking about
with my guy about how I,
you know,
even though on the tour I'll do some big
rooms,
I go,
I think I want to go to like a 1200
seater that to actually shoot it.
Yeah,
I think those,
those are in my experience as of recent,
that thousand to 1500 seat venue is the
most fun show.
It's like where it's big enough where
there's crazy energy,
but it's small enough.
You still kind of connect with the
audience.
Well,
sometimes those big shows that are crazy
fun too.
Like I did 6,000
seats in,
in um,
Dallas.
Fuck yeah.
Me and Tony and Ian were pulling up and
this is a big fucking traffic jam or
like,
God damn,
we're all these people going.
And then we realized,
Holy Shit,
they're going to the show coming to see
me.
That's crazy.
It was very bizarre.
Yeah.
That place was hyped up.
That was a lot of fun.
I did this one theater last year and
that was a 3000 seater.
Which one is Toronto?
Oh yeah,
I've done that.
That's great.
That was a great,
great.
Like for like a pretty big size.
Great Energy.
She ever do.
Massey Hall?
No,
I never did hall.
Some of these places you get to work at.
It's like they're like museums.
Yeah.
Well the Tabernacle is.
Yeah,
I mean that we're talking about.
I go.
Can you imagine if the Baptist ministers
that used to give sermons heard what I
was saying on their stage and I like how
upset they are.
Those guys.
That's what.
That was a baptist church.
Yeah.
I mean it doesn't have an Oregon behind
her,
so they still have.
The pipes are still there.
Yeah.
Wow.
Over 100 year old church.
It's fucking amazing venue.
Yeah,
it really is.
Yeah.
We're super lucky.
We get to work these places.
I did the king's theater in Brooklyn
last weekend I was at.
Oh amazing.
That's old,
right?
All this fuck from the 19 hundreds,
early 19 hundreds.
And then it closed down from like 77 to
2005.
And then in 2005 they started renovating
it.
It's a long time,
that close,
long time it was just sitting there and
then they,
they took forever to renovate it and
then they reopened it in 2015,
2010.
They restarted it somewhere.
Oh my God.
Dude.
I'm telling you,
you walk around the place and it's just
lavish.
How many seats is debt?
$3,000.
Oh my God.
It's gorgeous,
man.
That's in Brooklyn and it's in Brooklyn.
Brooklyn,
Brooklyn.
Well,
gorgeous.
Stunning.
Like the inside of it is amazing.
Not totally designed for comedy.
Yeah.
You know what's normally there were kind
of like,
I dunno bands probably.
I'm sure some comedy.
I think,
uh,
think Chris rock did it.
I think some people do comedy there,
but it's,
you know,
I think they've only been doing shows
there since 2015.
So what it says.
Hmm.
Yeah.
This is their calendar.
There's Jamie's boys.
How do you say their names?
Jesus fucking thing's broken.
This faded.
It sounds better than I did their show
on there.
I did their show a couple of weeks ago.
Amazing.
Those guys are hilarious.
Really?
Yeah.
There's so much fun.
They are a really good time and they
have,
they have such good rapport,
like chemistry together.
They're a blast.
Yeah.
And that show is,
it's a fun show.
They do like,
you know,
they just do commentary on a bunch of
bullshit,
whatever current events.
Weird shit happening and then they just
bring a guest on and they're very loose.
Very funny guys.
Man.
That's good to hear.
Yeah.
We need more good people.
If you go to,
if you go to bk next time,
you should definitely do.
Is that where they do it?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Advice offices there in Brooklyn.
Yeah,
five.
I haven't had much time to do anything,
man.
Yeah.
Well you're scrambling a little busy
scrambling.
Yeah.
No,
it's good.
It's good man.
Speaking to current events.
Is the president going to jail?
I'm trying to figure this out.
Is he going to jail?
It seems like.
Seems like some serious shit is going
down.
[inaudible] it sure feels like it is,
you know,
when it feels like it's really
interesting.
It's like a,
it's like you're watching a show.
It's a really entertaining show.
Yeah,
I mean I don't mind that house of cards
is in production because this is a good
show we're watching.
Yeah,
I mean it's ramping up whatever,
whatever is going on.
It's like they're building towards an
event and it seems like they have been
planning this,
like they're systematically attacking
different parts of his administration,
getting people to fold,
getting people to turn state's evidence,
getting people to to plead guilty and
they're slowly chipping away.
There's no way that the end result could
be like,
eh,
that's it.
We're done this.
As far as we got,
it feels like there's definitely a
shoe's going to drop.
Right?
I mean,
the crazy thing is they're going to get
them for campaign financing because of
his attorney paint off stormy Daniels.
I think the thing that I read,
I could be getting this wrong,
is that it's that pay off within a
certain number of days of the election,
right?
That starts to break a finance law.
I guess because they said that that
payment was within a certain number of
days of the election.
So what it means is that it's affecting
the election potentially,
is what.
Yeah,
what the accusation could be.
Isn't that interesting?
It's like you're paying someone to
affect opinion and so that's like,
it's a campaign finance violation.
Yeah.
It's also amazing that,
I dunno,
I mean I guess at the time somebody
comes to you with that check and you're
like,
sure.
But in retrospect,
thinking how much leverage she would've
had done.
If you go back then and,
and,
and she gets to say,
you want me to keep this thing silent?
No problem.
But you need to up that check.
Bill O'reilly,
Bill paid one lady 32 million.
Not.
Did he do?
No,
that's not a squeezing an ass cheek.
Right?
What did he do?
First of all,
how much money does he have?
Thirty $2.
Million is like,
just pay it.
Just pay it off.
Just write it off.
Yeah.
What does that.
A years our.
They have a lot of fucking settlements.
Roger ailes and seen the bit I'm doing
on Fox News.
No,
it's one of my favorite belly.
Oh,
I love doing this will be in the new
one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I look forward to seeing you there.
So it's such a fascinating little place
over there.
Yeah,
and right now they're what they're doing
for the most part.
Not every show,
but the show other than Tucker Carlson I
think is one of the few guys over there
that is,
he seems.
He seems the most reasonable.
Really?
Yes.
You think he's more reasonable than like
Shepard Smith?
Wow.
I never watched that guy.
Well that guy is saying he has a.
he's there,
but he seems to have like a little more
back,
like unbiased.
Balanced.
They give you are doing ecstasy with
Shepard Smith.
He tried to kiss you?
I hope so.
I think I've been losing weight.
Yeah,
but the
rest of it.
My point is the rest of this show seems
like state run propaganda.
Here's,
and here's the thing.
He also,
when it's not a secret,
it's kind of fascinating,
right?
That it's not a secret that he has real
relationships with multiple on air
talent.
Like the president is like I'm friends
with Jeanine Pirro.
I'm really good friends with Sean
Hannity.
I'm really good.
I've watched.
Yeah,
everyday.
I watched a morning show called Fox and
friends and as they report things I
tweet out like policy change based on
this morning show and it's not secret,
like if you see the segment and then
he's like,
like there was this aired at 6:30
AM,
6:32.
He's like we're going to have to do
something about this shit,
and they just did a segment on it and
then that also throws his aids and his
staff a curve balls because there'll be
not expecting that he's going to bring
this up,
but he sees it on tv and there and then
they have to go like,
yeah,
of course we are going to do that
because keep him from the TV.
Yeah,
it's fucking nuts.
He watches a lot of cable TV.
They say watches eight hours a day.
He doesn't like to go to the office
early and that's one of my other
favorite ones.
Like the like John Kelly has been like,
you've got to get here earlier.
That's hilarious.
I said I sit out for a.
He was showing up at 11 and that they
were trying to get them to come at nine
and then I think they settled on 10 or
something.
Yeah.
Just want to get their fucking nine.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
It's so interesting.
They really.
He doesn't get us into a war.
Having him as the president will be very
beneficial.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I think that we're going to
realize how fucking crazy it is to give
one person so much power based on a
popularity contest.
It.
It does kind of highlight the absurdity
of not just of him of the presidency.
Right.
Completely absurd.
Yeah.
We'd never do it that way today if we
had no government at all,
if we lived in some sort of Bizarro
universe where a government had never
been established when decided enough is
enough.
We can't live with anarchy anymore.
We need to have some sort of a system of
rules,
checks and balances and put an.
We never say,
all right,
let's have a popularity contest.
See One dude,
and let's let them get financed by giant
groups of people know.
That shit's all.
It's ridiculous.
It's so fucked.
I know this and then it seems like
everybody agrees that that's fine,
but they never changes.
Yeah.
I've been hearing for a decade plus
about campaign finance reform stuff and
then it's still,
you know,
powerful Super Pacs,
collect them.
Oh,
we'll just find a loophole and then we
get them money that way.
I mean,
nothing changes.
Well,
the just the amount of money and
influence,
it's all tied in together to try to
completely shake that off.
You'd have to get people to be 100
percent ethical.
They would have to say,
you know what?
This is just not the way to run the
government.
It's not right for the people,
but they're not going to do that.
Of course,
too much influence.
It just shows you how sneaky and snaky
the whole thing is,
but it's also really interesting too,
because we're going to be forced with
this guy because of all this fucking
chaos.
We're going to be forced to reexamine
how we do things.
Maybe it'll be a little change for the
next president with the.
I'm sorry.
The real worry would be that he would
get through eight years.
Then one of his sons would take over.
I guess it's not out of the realm of
possibility.
It's not even a little.
I have this theory that I think he
actually in a way will really relish and
enjoy the midterms in November going
Democrat because that totally feeds into
his.
They're attacking and like being able to
be like course nothing gets done because
he's fucking concert or an office now
and I think that he would really
actually almost enjoy because he loves
combative,
combative relationship.
I think he's actually going to.
If it goes that way,
I think he will like really enjoy it.
I think so,
but I also think that he likes winning
though.
He does like winning.
Of course he likes winning and it's a
compulsive.
You can tell that when they'll,
you know oprah,
you're going to run.
She's like,
no.
He's like,
I hope she runs.
Kick her fucking ass.
He can't help himself.
You know?
He has that kind of competitive side to
him.
Yeah.
No,
he definitely does.
Well they say they don't want them to
testify because they know they're going
to catch him lying there.
Like,
you can't do it.
Don't worry,
I'm not gonna lie it.
All his lawyers have said like,
a hundred percent,
don't do that.
He was like,
oh,
I'll think about it.
Which means that like,
he,
you know,
because he,
he says that a lot with uh,
you can tell them when they have those
off the cuff,
you know,
press,
when he lets the press in,
they'll ask him something,
he'll be like,
we'll see what happens.
Which is totally like,
I might do it,
I might not,
but you know,
that everybody in his size,
like please don't say anything at this
point.
They might not even be.
They might be like,
go ahead.
Yeah,
yeah.
Go ahead.
Tough guy.
Go talk,
go talk.
Who knows,
man,
I'll get another job.
How amazing would it be to watch that
deposition or,
or,
you know,
uh,
interview.
Do you remember when Bill Clinton was
grilled about Monica Lewinsky?
The word is,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
And just the term sexual relations,
as I understand it,
the way I understand the word,
that's not it.
Yeah.
No,
I mean that was fascinating.
Eight.
He's so shameless.
Well,
not just that,
it's just,
it seems so strange.
Yeah.
Back then in the 19 nineties to be able
to watch the president in video get
grilled and clearly they wanted to
release this video to humiliate them.
Of course,
you know,
but it was just bizarre.
It's like I've never,
we'd never seen anything like this.
You've never seen a sitting president
like getting grilled by people and
especially about sex and the shift mode.
Like uh,
you know,
we knew him as this.
Obviously you'd see him on the campaign
trail or meeting people.
He's like this super charming,
right?
Like personable guy.
Yeah.
Really good at being basically a
celebrity.
You don't really good at that.
And he's like,
you know,
knows how to be a politician.
But in that deposition,
I mean he switched onto lawyer mode and,
and like,
I'm not here to charm you motherfucker,
because he was spin on is what does is
mean is like,
I remember just,
I mean I'm a kid,
I think I was in high school watching
that and be like,
how does anyone struggle with is like,
is this.
And I didn't know he was like playing a
game with them too,
you know?
Oh yeah.
Well they were playing lawyer games.
Yeah.
Total war games.
Trump can't do that.
He's not smart enough to do that.
No,
he's not a lawyer.
So he's not.
I wouldn't say he's not.
I don't think that trump is not smart.
I think he's smart.
I've,
I've.
Especially when you listen to interviews
of him from the past,
like he's like,
there's some interviews in the past.
Very articulate.
Yeah.
And obviously been very successful in
business,
but I don't think he's an interested in
expanding his horizons mentally.
I don't think he's interested in
reading.
No,
I don't think he also thinks that he
really 100 percent does the,
did run his business off of instinct
and,
and like gut and relationships and
loyalty and stuff that he's promoting.
When they say like,
you can't do that here.
He's like trucking,
mark.
I'm the president.
Fuck off.
People want it.
Do you want to read this briefing?
No,
I don't like to be brief.
I don't like to read.
Yeah,
he doesn't like to read.
They say they put the word trump in his
briefings a bunch of times,
just so that he reads it screwed ahead.
What?
This is about me.
What else about me?
Amazing French.
I don't know,
man.
It does feel like it's going to star
report.
This is what?
Yeah,
blood to a star.
Yeah.
This will be like Miller's report that
would be coming out maybe later this
year or something like that.
Is that the equivalent?
I don't know.
Uh,
yeah.
I guess if they get,
if they get to a real special council
report.
Yeah,
sure.
The Mueller thing is so strange because
technically can he fire Mueller?
Well that's,
there was a big article about whether or
not.
So the White House said that they
believe that he does have the power to
do that.
But.
And you don't know if that's.
I mean,
you would think that that means that
they're sent.
He just wants to put that signal out
there,
like,
I can't do this.
But there was other legal minds that
said that he couldn't do it,
that he would have to get a bra because
sessions has recused himself from this.
Uh,
the deputy attorney general Rod
Rosenstein is it,
and that he would have to get him to do
it and then they said that,
you know,
that he would,
would not do that unless,
I mean Rosenstein said he wouldn't do it
unless a Mueller had done ms.ms
dot
conduct.
Right.
So,
and,
and that if the president tried to get
him do that,
he would resign,
in which case they would have to get
another person either appointed to do it
or whoever's below him to do it.
So it's a,
it's a really good episode.
I can't remember a time where I felt
like there was nobody at the wheel more
than I do now.
Yeah.
It does feel like chaos.
Like it's,
there's all people that are in
positions,
you know,
there's the secretary of state,
there's the chief of staff,
there's all these,
there's all these different people that
are in positions,
but it feels like a,
uh,
like make believe and you know,
what happens because this happens
everywhere.
We get lost in our experience of it
because we live here.
I'm really fascinated by how it looks
outside of have here.
Oh yeah.
Am I.
It must really seem like an even crazier
show.
Oh,
it's got to.
And then Mike Pence is holding Bible
study classes for the first time in 100
years in the White House lacked.
Yeah.
Really?
And women aren't allowed to read what?
Yes.
No,
no.
Women read the Bible there.
This is for real.
No women.
The women are not teaching.
There's no women teaching these Bible
study.
No,
he doesn't.
He doesn't like dinner with that Mama
there.
No.
No women next to him at dinner.
Mike pence must be an animal.
I'm just trying to keep it together.
He just backed up the ball hog and yeah,
just got to keep them away.
No dinner with women.
No women.
Mike Penn Sponsors Whitehouse Bible
study led by Anti Lgbtq anti women.
Extremist.
That this is real.
This is what we got to be careful for
folks.
We've got to be careful of this.
This guy could be president and that
ain't no better.
This is.
This guy is fucking radical.
Radical.
Fundamentalist Christianity.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Ooh.
Let me see that little bit bigger.
What does it say?
Bible Study Group led by Ralph
Drollinger,
an extremist who says Lgbtq people are
illegitimate.
Secretary of state nominee Mike Pompeo,
attorney general jeff sessions and
Education Secretary Betsy Devos attended
the weekly sessions in Washington.
While trolling ger claims he doesn't
tell members,
he's advised in the past how to vote.
He notes that he would,
in quotes,
put the blueprint on the engineer's seat
on the train.
I don't know what's going on.
People look to their faith as a source
of guidance and inspiration and Lgbtq
people in our family and friends are no
different.
Drone jurors,
brand of faith,
however,
seeks to drive a wedge between the LG,
that lgbt thing.
First of all,
how did trans people get locked in with
queer people or gay people?
Isn't that a different thing?
It is.
I think they're just all marginalized.
Marginalized groups.
Yeah,
but they do.
You know there's a to an a plus.
Do you know that?
Yes.
Now it's a and a plus.
This is like a.
This is an abbreviated list,
but if you really want to be completely
not inclusive,
you have to include asexual people as
well.
They feel marginalized because they're
not trans than not gay.
They're not straight,
they just not sex weight.
Why cute?
Q for Queer Queer,
but why is that as African Gay and
lesbian?
Because it's just Ahmad.
I'm just a weird guy.
I don't know.
What is queer?
I thought that men,
people right now are screaming at us.
Gendered assholes.
CISGENDER,
white,
privileged assholes.
Pretty wealthy to um,
I don't know.
Acu.
Why?
That is different.
What is queer?
What is the devastating what?
It's good because we're used to be just
gain gay.
Right?
So Google what is the cue and Lgbtq and
then let's get into a.
and a plus is asexual as a plus.
By the way.
A huge thanks.
I got a huge gift.
Goodie bag.
Can I say thanks to the roots of fight
guy?
Oh,
this is a great soccer going on right
now.
That's crazy.
Julio Cesar Chavez shirt.
We didn't even plan that.
We did not plan this.
I came home to a bunch of free shit,
like the best.
Okay.
LGBT G,
L or G L B e t on what is initialism?
Initialism.
I never said that word before.
That stands for lesbian,
gay,
bisexual,
transgender.
To recognize this inclusion.
A popular variant adds the queue for
those who identify as queer or are
questioning their sexual identity.
That makes you like.
I'm not sure.
Talking about Andy Dick.
Yeah,
I might be.
It might be.
I'm not sure.
Or at least that's an answer.
It's fence sitters.
Yeah,
I'm here.
I'm there.
They should have to fence it and my
genders,
whatever.
Yeah.
What is it?
Movement.
A fluid gender fluid.
That's my favorite.
You're a girl.
One day a boy.
The next day I had somebody email me
too.
They said at work they said,
you know,
you can pick your gender for emails,
for company emails.
So like this person picked a agenda and
he's like,
I think I'm going to do this.
And I said,
well what if your gender is changing?
I think you should send them an email
every day.
So it'd be like today.
Yeah.
He's like,
I'm going to try it.
See what happens.
What do they.
They can't say shit.
I guess they can't.
No,
you can't say shit all.
You have to just keep a straight face
today.
Identify as a woman.
You,
you literally can do whatever you want.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Which I mean,
and then people argue that you should
have the right to do that,
to change whenever you want.
I guess.
I mean it's not convenient for everyone,
but I guess you can.
Yeah,
I guess you can.
It's not the worst thing in the world.
No.
But when,
when do we call it nonsense?
Yeah.
I guess there would be a limit because
if you switched it on the hour,
like get the fuck Outta here with that.
Yeah.
Well what if you decide that you like
identify with things that aren't even
real?
Like elves does Elf kin.
It's a good point.
I think I would have you just decide
that I'm in now.
But again,
if somebody came in your office,
especially if they were a valuable
employee and they were like,
I'm an Elf and they had a straight face
and you're like,
you're a high producer here at the
company.
Okay.
But if someone comes into your office
and they're a woman and they say,
today I'm a man.
Yeah,
today.
Yes.
And I reserved the right to be a woman
back again tomorrow.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you have a penis?
No.
No,
just to man,
man.
Today.
Okay.
There they,
they're letting you decide whether or
not you can accept nonsense.
That's true.
I mean,
here's the thing,
it's,
it's spreading though.
It is growing and it's really a matter
of how many people that don't do that
except that this is a new reality.
Well,
and then there's also the thing that we
all know is that some people have an
extreme desire to be special without
doing any work whatsoever.
Yeah.
They don't want to have to work to be
special.
They just want to be special.
So if they can just say there's a lot of
them on instagram.
Yes.
Instagram.
Yeah.
If they could just say they're a part of
some marginalized group,
then instantaneously they get more
respect and this is not taken away from
the people that I think are legitimately
trans.
I think there's definitely people that
are legitimately transfers.
I think those people that are
legitimate,
Lee Trans,
she'd be upset at these gender fluid.
Fucking weird.
I was bouncing back and forth all day.
There's a radio lab about that where the
guy decides during the conversation that
he's a man and then he's a woman.
Now I switched over.
Now I'm Paul,
now I'm betty.
I just changed.
How do we address that as 100 percent?
Either you're fucking with me or you're
mentally ill,
right?
You can't say mentally ill when it comes
to gender.
That's the one area where mentally ill,
like if it's violence.
Okay.
If it's impulsive things like gambling
or something along those lines,
all that stuff.
You could say you're mentally ill.
You cannot say you're mentally ill when
it comes to gender.
Why?
Because we're scared.
We're scared of being called out,
but if somebody is like,
I'm talking right now and they switch
and this switch gender again,
then they switched and they switched the
fourth time in an hour conversation.
We're supposed to just be like,
that's exactly that fucking dude that
we've been sending each other back and
forth.
Homeboys,
instagram.
What is his name?
Kyle.
Done again?
Holy Shit.
Is he funny?
He's so funny.
He's.
There's a guy named kyle done again.
He's on instagram and he's doing that
face swap thing.
He takes Caitlyn Jenner's face and Kim
Kardashians space in all the family.
He does all.
He does all their voices on a fake face
times.
Oh.
And then he does.
He'll do trump talking to sessions.
He uh,
he's really good.
He's a really funny comic.
I've never seen his standup,
but my favorite instagram place over
this play this.
So
I'm close to my first female orgasm
isn't quite working.
Oh,
that's good.
You did some shit on there.
You're distracting me.
Therapy,
right?
I just want checkers head girl.
He's got his whole fucking instagram is
filled with those maps.
Yeah,
they're hilarious.
And it's right now it's kind of a
secret,
like not a lot of people.
No,
no.
I could get 44,000
people just change.
That is one of the best instagram pages.
I've reposted his videos.
There's.
So what does this one?
Sure.
Hey,
here's a problem.
Let's go bro.
Come on Bro.
I'll knock you out by the style.
I'll kick you in the nuts bottles.
Okay.
Looking to the left.
You'd make you could take tape.
Tape that I'm going to kiss you on the
mouth.
Kiss you on the map of your throat.
Yeah.
That deal.
Yeah,
yeah.
We feel good,
but okay.
I mean,
how much time does this dude have?
This is a guy with no kids.
Definitely get down to center.
If I made one of these,
my wife would be like the fuck.
Are you going?
Oh,
this is what.
Okay.
You still want the glasses?
This one is just a silly one.
Okay,
good.
I love this one.
Watch this one.
So sorry.
Yes ma'am.
Guess what?
His real mom triggered by chicken.
But chicken.
That's what you're supposed to guess.
Ma'Am.
Guess she's on the phone right here.
Bam.
Triggering.
But guess what?
Guess what?
Guess what,
Ma'am?
Ma'Am,
ma'am.
ma'am,
guess why chicken?
He's 40.
He's a funny dude in New York guy.
Was He an La Guy?
I think he lives in La.
Oh my God.
He's funny,
man.
Yeah.
See me live at Largo in La.
May Fourteenth.
Go see him now.
God.
Holy Shit.
And just go to his instagram.
You spend your whole day because his
instagram is one of the one of the few
instagrams where literally everything's
funny.
Yeah,
like half of my shit.
I'm most of my shit.
I'm not trying to be funny.
No,
that guy's funny on all of them.
It's just a.
it's a party.
Fucking hilarious man.
Guess what?
Chicken Butt Horn.
Mothered.
Sleeping.
Trump impressions of hilarious.
I know him and bite.
That was nuts when him and biden were
talking shit on twitter about fighting
Biden.
Oh,
Cindy's.
He kick his ass.
His ass by the trumps like you'd go down
quick,
quick.
You ever think there was gonna be a time
in your lifetime where the president of
the United States was saying would kick
someone's ass?
No.
Kick your ass easy,
easy,
and he doesn't even fight the keys.
He doesn't even exercise at all.
He said he would run.
He would have run into that Parklin and
school without a.
without a gun.
Yeah.
I would have run.
I'll run in there without a course.
I would have.
Would have taken the guy out.
It's nuts.
It's nuts to say that if that was the
only thing he had said in the last year,
people were like,
that is fucking a fascinating guy.
It's a fascinating study and watching
someone like we,
we have this strange attraction to
people that have like powerful
confidence like that.
Like we want to watch it play out that
guy.
We don't want to watch that guy.
Just play out watches confidence here
goes watch,
watch them.
Well,
a lot of people are really attracted,
really attracted instinctively,
intuitively to somebody with the WHO,
you know the balls to say anything.
Oh yeah.
That's a really appealing quality to a
lot of people.
Yeah,
we've never had one like this though,
right?
No.
Well he was fun when he was on the
contender or whatever the fuck it was.
The apprentice.
Yeah,
he was fun.
and like a stern always said that,
you know,
he's like,
I've had a great guest.
Yeah,
there's always a great guest.
It's a funny,
but he cultivated that whole thing his
whole life and then all of a sudden you
become president.
You're supposed to be a different thing.
He's like,
no,
I am.
It's what I do.
Bang Hoes,
man.
Did you see me?
Said that he asked me.
He asked me to check on the pep story.
Yeah,
because Melania was like,
serious,
you made him piss on you didn't.
I swear that's not true and I'm going to
get the FBI on the case on the pis
tapes.
Get them on the piss tapes.
That's how confident I am.
That cold call me.
Can you look into that?
Do I have your loyalty?
Checking those pits tapes on real man.
Crazy man.
That'd be another thing.
Would be fun to watch other pis tapes.
He's fun for comedy though.
Tell you what,
because he's,
he's like,
Eh,
at the same time
you're seeing this massive political
correctness backlash where like people
are angry at,
at him and they,
they're like pushing really hard and the
other direction.
So it's created this very volatile
social environment.
You know the,
the Zeit geist yeah.
Verizon.
It's possible.
Trump was with hookers peeing on each
other.
It's possible.
Well,
how did he say that in an interview?
Right?
How did he say it though?
I want to hear it like his actual words.
If it's on here,
this is to.
He says it's possible.
It could it be like,
I don't know,
per conversation about how the trump
team would position this and what they
could say about this.
They actually started talking about
drafting a press release with us still
sitting there and the reason that was so
striking to me is that that's just not
done.
That the intelligence community does
intelligence.
The White House does pr and spin.
You also said you were struck by what?
They didn't ask very much.
No one to my recollection asked,
so what?
What's coming next from the Russians?
How might we stop it?
What's the future look like?
It was all might not come up.
What can we say about what they did and
how it affects the election that we just
had call me then asked to meet alone
with trump,
but was it a longer than trump's ties to
Russia,
including allegations of trump's
encounters with prostitutes,
Moscow.
I'm about to meet with a person who
doesn't know me.
It's just been elected president of the
United States by all accounts and from
my watching him during the campaign
could be volatile and I'm about to talk
to him about allegations that he was
involved with prostitutes in Moscow and
that the Russians taped it and have
leverage over him.
Was there any choice there a why?
If this was salacious and this
particular part of the dossier?
Unverified.
Still unverified by the way?
Yes.
So far as when I got fired,
it was unverified.
Did you tell him that the steele dossier
had been financed by his political
opponents?
No,
I didn't.
I don't even think I used the term
steele dossier.
I just talked about additional material,
but did he have a right to know that
that had been financed by his political
opponents?
That I don't know the answer to,
that it wasn't necessary for.
My goal was
okay for us to play to get us to stop a
second ago.
We can't really play that I the whole
thing.
That's what I was.
Yeah.
At the minute.
Are we gonna get in trouble?
I don't think so.
I don't know.
I'm gonna come down on us.
No,
I mean it might notice a ABC News owns
this interview,
so.
MMM.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cut it out then.
Either way.
Let's take it from here.
There's some APP,
some he said it's possible.
So people listening,
we just played it.
Jamie's going to edit it out later so we
don't get in trouble.
We don't get pulled off of Youtube.
Yeah,
it should be okay.
But.
But I'm just madness.
The whole thing is just so crazy.
I just,
I'm glued to my seat.
I can't,
I,
I can't see where it's going.
I know,
I know.
It's why,
uh,
there's so much coming at every day that
there's,
you know,
you realize that there's entire
entertainment shows now just addressing
the reality.
That is our political spectrum now.
Why doesn't he have to take a pee test?
You have to take a peek.
Trump,
you have to take a pee test.
If you work at ups,
they had to check.
You give me something.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I think he's on speed.
You do 100 percent.
He doesn't sleep.
He doesn't sleep a lot.
There's a lot of energy and there's some
evidence from many different reporters
that one reporter even named the
pharmacy where he used to get a speed.
He was on diet pills that you're only
supposed to take for a little while.
He took him for like six years and then
there was another reporter we talked
about recently that was saying that he's
on one of the fence.
He's won one of those now,
which totally makes sense.
He is 70 what?
Seventy one?
Yeah.
How does he have so much fucking energy?
That guy has a shit ton of energy.
I mean,
when he was on the campaign trail,
he just would go,
go,
go.
It was like three stops of fucking day,
you know,
getting on plane land somewhere.
I do a rally good.
No Problem Eating Kentucky Fried Chicken
wasn't eating healthy fried chicken.
I know.
And uh,
yeah man,
I think he's on speed and it makes me
want to get on speed pace.
We want to be more productive.
I mean that's,
there's so many people I know that are
on adderall.
So many.
I've never tried it.
I never have either.
Jamie gave me some of them scared,
just sitting around.
Do you watch that documentary yet?
No,
it just talks about how many people are
on.
It just is crazy.
So many all day everyday.
Well,
um,
my stem cell doctor was telling me that
when he was in medical school that the
people that it was with,
like all the,
you know,
the people who's going to school with,
they were all taken adderall and he was
like,
I would watch them finish papers and I
just couldn't understand where they had
the energy from.
And he's like,
dude,
we're on adderall.
Like this is the way to go and just
like,
Holy Shit.
He's like,
it makes you feel like you have to get
on it because all these people are so,
so productive when they're on it.
I've heard comics talk about it to
comics really don't think I would think
you'd be to ramped up.
I think when they said they had like a
lot of work to do those jobs and they're
like,
I gotta get this done and get that done.
Yeah.
The downsides got to be rough though.
Uh,
I don't.
Yeah.
I don't know anything about it really.
I mean I know that it's popular and
people have been taking it for,
but I mean like when you come off it,
I'm sure Jamie did you ever.
You did it right?
I did it twice I think,
but I think I also took two different
versions of it because there's different
kinds.
There's not just like,
was it in a row and now you're taking
adderall?
Was it to work?
Or like just recreation had like art
projects or something.
I was trying to get done.
Like I really wanted to get it done.
I was also interested to see what it
would be like because I've never taken
it and I've heard friends take it.
Some,
some of my friends really just take it
to drink more,
most of it because we're not in college
anymore,
you know?
But uh,
yeah.
So the one time I took it I had a day
off and it kept me up the whole time,
which is what I thought would happen.
But then the next day I was also,
I was just still up.
I tried to go to bed,
couldn't go to,
couldn't fall asleep with a,
it's out of your system.
It's just a little bit to like five
milligrams,
maybe 10 of the slow release because
there's also fast release.
You can pop the pill and take the salts
directly in without having a time
release.
So there's different variations.
What about the day after that?
Do you just crash?
Super.
It was fine.
I was normal.
I just thought I was.
I was afraid to go to work.
So I was serving.
I thought I was going to crash while I
was serving people's tables and drop
food everywhere.
I have the day off,
so.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Hmm.
Oh,
you remember Robert Schimmel?
Yeah.
He accidentally took it once.
Accidentally.
He got the.
So not bob shoveled personality.
They.
No,
it's not.
Yeah.
He was like super mellow.
But uh,
he told me,
uh,
he accidentally took it and he called
his doctor panicking because he had
serious heart condition.
Yeah.
And the doctor said,
you're going to be fine.
Just,
it's just gonna.
It's gonna last for about 12 hours.
And he goes,
man,
I got so much shit done.
He goes,
I just sat in front of my computer and
organize my notes.
I got all my act together just makes you
really productive apparently,
but we're gonna you know,
it's going to change the way people
interact.
It's going to change the way he made.
If more and more people continue to do
this,
going to change the way people feel
about other people,
they're going to be all jazzed up.
You think he's on some version of that
president?
Yes.
I want to try it.
And I think if these,
if these reporters are correct,
pull up that story about the reporter
that even listed the Duane Reed pharmacy
in New York where trump was on the shit
for six years and then they think that
trump is on something now and they even
specified the stuff that he's on.
Hillary was on some shit too.
She's on either in new vigil or pro
vigil.
They're both very similar.
Um,
but that's the stuff that they give to
narcolepsy.
People with narcolepsy.
Really awake.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It keeps you awake,
man.
If you have to drive,
he'd pop on them.
New vigils.
That's an interesting one because it
doesn't give you the same sort of
speediness I'm really bad at night
driving.
I feel tired.
Those lines they started hitting into
just to embrace you will,
we'll keep you calm.
And if you,
if it's warm,
if you're in a cold place,
you know the heat on in the car,
that's rough.
Cold with heat driving by yourself on
the rope.
No good.
Especially with no lights on the road.
Night,
night,
night.
Have you ever fallen asleep and woken
yourself up?
Changing lanes?
Yes.
That's terrifying.
Yeah.
It's not good and secure as it should
and it scares the shit out of me
fighting Jeremy.
I can't find him because he took it off
the Internet.
He had the boys cleaned it up.
Why's?
Why that?
Michael Cohen on that case got a big
Dick.
Michael Cohen,
that Guy Hilarious.
All of them in.
It's like where do they go from
characters,
man?
It was real weird.
Nothing was coming up on Google like it
really was being taken off really well.
I found it.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Okay.
Fun Fact.
Nineteen 82.
Trump started taking amphetamine
derivatives.
Abused them.
Only supposed to take two for 25 days.
Stayed on him for eight years.
Really?
Wow.
Right.
Here's the White House.
Admitted it to me saying only for a
short time for diet when he was not
overweight.
I countered with medical records.
They cut me off.
People misreading drug was die.
Ethel probe,
p n d I e t h y l p r o p t I o n 75
milligrams a day prescription filled at
Duane reed on 57th street in Manhattan.
Not that I know things get crazy.
I'm the doctor wrote the prescription Dr
Joseph Greenberg diagnosed him with
metabolic imbalance,
which we have never heard about.
Again.
Greenberg was later publicly slammed as
someone who would provide uppers to rich
people in Manhattan,
metabolic imbalance,
if true could be an electrolyte
insufficiencies,
anaerobic imbalances,
acid imbalances,
and as sort of an assortment of related
disorders that can have serious health
consequences.
Yet his other doctor,
Dr Harold Bornstein said,
been trump's dr since 1988.
Never mentioned the metal bulk and
balance found by Greenberg.
So this guy would just like Tommy,
you've got a medical imbalance or
metabolic metabolic imbalance.
What I say here,
take these,
take these.
What are they?
That's fucking great.
That's what they are.
How do I take it?
Before,
I don't know,
eight years,
but there was another one.
Yeah,
there's.
That's the amphetamine.
A drug of phenylalanine.
See,
this is m,
m fab pra Moan,
and fet promotes a stimulant of the
phenol phen phen phen asylum mean
amphetamine.
So this is the shit they think he's on
now.
Yeah,
that's what came up when I grew up with
that.
Yeah,
they think he's on something now.
I think.
Look man,
I think this is a not so dirty little
secret.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it.
We take coffee.
That's a stimulant.
Sure.
These people are just taking pills.
Yeah,
I don't think he does.
Right.
Isn't he like a not a coffee guy?
No,
I don't think he drinks coffee.
I don't think he drinks booze at all.
No.
So,
so he's just in the uppers diet coke
though,
right?
Yeah.
Like 19 dcs.
Press downs.
Those.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
That's caffeine,
right?
You well,
yeah,
he's definitely into caffeine.
So he drinks the caffeine all day and
he's taken these uppers and that's how
he gets shit done for America.
That's how it brings coal back.
Yeah.
It's bringing sexy back to strange mean
the,
those pills.
The thing about when you think about
amphetamines,
when you think about brash decisions,
think about people that are overly,
overly confident,
you know,
arrogant.
Like,
look,
this is exactly what you expect from
him.
Totally.
Super aggressive.
Yeah.
It doesn't strike me as a crazy
conspiracy.
No.
To say that that's happening.
It's fascinating.
But now that's my question,
like why don't they test them?
Yeah.
We found out he's off the charts.
You get his charts backing like,
whoa.
It's just like cocaine out of control.
He's like,
yeah,
whatever.
I do an eight ball a day.
So a ball while here.
A little there.
What do you think Putin's doing?
Trying to keep the wolves out of our
door.
Do you see that video that was going
around yesterday of the dog that got
killed by the two wolves?
Oh No,
it was horrible.
German shepherd.
Oh,
don't show it please.
German shepherd.
They dragged it out of the yard and
they're killing it in the street on
security camera.
We're like,
we're part of the,
I don't know,
somewhere in a community.
It's a neighborhood neighborhood though.
I mean it's like a paved street here.
Coyotes at night.
I see them during the day,
sometimes two running down the street.
One killed my chicken last week.
Really?
Two weeks ago,
two weeks ago.
And another one got a chicken.
Do you feel like you're just gone around
the other day?
They were on the roof of the chicken.
The Hen house plucking at the pulling of
the chicken wire,
trying to pull the chicken wire off.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Especially if they're do it for the
roof.
They do it from the roof.
They're going to fall in and if they
fall,
fallen,
they going to be stuck in the chicken
coop.
Just kill them all and yeah,
they'll just kill them all and then I'll
kill them.
Yeah.
But that's just fucked.
What would you do?
Shoot him?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I wonder if my neighbors would tell the
cops if they're heard pop,
pop,
pop.
We just hit him with a gun.
That shotgun fucking head checking.
Uh,
I don't know what I would use.
It'd be hard to shoot him with a bow
because I'd have to get them to sit
still.
Right.
Well I drew back and then they'd be
running around the chicken coop.
So I'd be in there with them in the
chicken coop.
No.
Good.
Like what would they do?
Would they attack me?
Maybe.
Maybe if they're feeling panicked to
that panic,
they felt trapped.
It certainly will be running around in
circles with whether or not they decide
to just leap at me,
bite my face off.
Maybe a rifle.
That'd be the easiest.
Probably loud as fuck.
Super loud.
Yeah.
You,
you have a couple of those going off in
the backyard.
People gonna call the cops.
Oh yeah.
But then would you get in trouble for
that?
I don't think you're supposed to shoot a
gun in your yard,
Tom.
Yes,
but what if you feel threatened?
Well,
if you were,
if someone was breaking into your home
and threatening your life and you shot
them,
that would be one thing.
Defensive Life and property.
That's not this.
This is like you have a varmint in your
backyard.
I don't think you'd get in trouble for
killing coyotes.
Coyotes
are thought of as like rats as crazy as
that because we have a hierarchy when it
comes to animals.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean we love,
we love dogs and cats,
but we don't really give a shit about
mice.
No.
Oh No.
Everywhere you go.
You buy mice traps.
Snap their necks.
Electrocute them.
Yeah.
Even glue traps.
Those are the worst mice.
Get stuck on the glue.
Put One of those.
I tell you that like 10 years ago I
lived in silver lake.
I see rats crawling over here.
Rats.
You see rats all the time.
I went to this at this office.
I was working part time and they go,
uh,
the guy was like,
oh,
just take these,
uh,
take these rat traps with you,
like glue traps and they'll get stuck in
it and uh,
it,
it's perfect.
That's what you should do.
So I took it,
put some peanut butter on it,
like you said,
put it in the backyard and the next day
they were flipped over and shit on.
It's like the rat step.
Then it was like,
fuck this,
flipped it over and took a shit on it.
Like,
fuck you,
man.
I was like,
I told him.
He was like,
oh,
that's pretty big rat then.
Okay.
I caught a big one in my backyard,
my garage rather when I lived in Encino,
uh,
the,
the trap came down,
snapped his neck,
killed him.
I went out there,
he's up fat boy.
I was like,
Ooh,
there's a big rat.
I'm like,
I'll get that in the morning.
I just left it out there.
I went back in the morning.
It was eating everything except the
tail.
They ate him though.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
On each other.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
The tear each other up.
Did you see that rats documentary on
Netflix?
No.
Woo.
Say it should.
I don't like rats scare you.
Yeah.
I don't need it in my head.
I don't need it.
Need it.
Jeremy saw it.
Right.
It's fucking great.
Let me just makes you realize the sheer
volume of them in American cities
everywhere.
Oh yeah.
It's more rats in New York City than
there are people.
They said that they'll get through the,
you know,
or mice.
At least we'll get through a hole the
size of a dime or something like that.
They're flexible and they're.
They just shove their way in.
They're not like us.
They're crazy.
They're crazy smart.
To the older rats,
they'll send younger rats to go check on
bates and stuff like that.
Or someone leaves behind rat bait that
is poisoning.
The old rats will sit back like,
man,
I don't think so on the young rats,
like,
move over here.
Was that food?
Your car,
your car is not going to eat.
You're not going to eat.
Good man.
Good.
I eat and then he'll eat and die and
they'll go,
yep.
I thought so.
So because of that,
they've developed poisoned.
That takes like 10,
11 hours to kick in.
So one rattle eat it.
He's like,
how are you feeling?
I'm feeling great,
I'm fine,
I'm fine.
And then the other rats will eat it too
because they're like,
oh,
he's okay.
And then yeah.
So they're,
they're,
they're developing these slow release
poisons,
but then you just have this rotting rat
like you're not stop.
There's no way you're going to eradicate
the problem.
Like if someone said,
hey,
I've got a solution to completely
eliminate all the rats were New York
City,
like,
no you don't.
Is there no solution?
There's no solution isn't.
No.
Unless you little robot rats that eat
rats.
Oh right.
All they do is eat rats.
That's what you'd have to let loose.
He'd have to let loose a scourge.
Just a pack of robot rat eating rats
that only eat rats and they can do what
rats do there.
That's the one that had a bought flying.
It's body that was like the size of a
football.
What was in his body?
A Bot fly that lava.
See that whole next to his neck.
That was a.
There was a parasite in there that was
that big.
That's like if you had a soccer ball
growing out of your chest.
Yeah,
and the rats dead and that thing is
alive still.
Really?
Yeah.
It's in the dock.
Yeah,
on the.
And they were finding all these crazy
diseases that are just totally fatal,
just floating around inside the rat's
body and rats,
like they're fine,
but it would kill us.
How's that happened?
Oh,
there's a foul,
foul little creature.
So fat.
Why don't we just set like all these
sewers on fire that's going to work like
a little kid then?
Yeah,
it's like a little kid solution.
Just fucking poor gasoline in the
sewage,
but there's certain problems that we
just don't have an answer to.
That's the problem of rats in cities.
They don't have an answer to.
I mean you can mitigate it by
controlling your trash or this or that.
There's a few things you could do to
sort of keep them like at least at bay,
but they're going to be hungry and
they're going to be searching around and
people are always going to leave
garbage.
There's always going to be food in New
York,
in New York City.
Right.
So much filth.
How many rats do you think are in
Manhattan?
Oh,
let's see how many people.
I think there's $7,000,000.
This is about eight point 6 million pa
point 6 million people.
I'd say 13 million rats come.
I'm going to go with 24.
This estimate says there are
approximately 33 point $6 million,
which is as many as five rats per
person.
So many.
Wow.
That's.
How do they get that?
And there's different ones.
Uptown and downtown.
There's a dip.
Genetically Genetically Distinguishable
groups.
How many groups to to genetically
distinguishable groups of uptown and
downtown?
They have those uppity.
Uptown Rats,
upper west side,
rat hoes.
Fucking upper east side.
The lounge in those cool soho rats.
Bark has genetically distinct uptown and
downtown that is fucking crazy.
There's so many of them too,
and when you see them there's like.
It's such a like an instantaneous
feeling of panic and like moving
quickly.
I'm terrified of them.
I don't like it at all.
No ones running around your house like
Jesus.
Oh Man.
I to get my son.
He's over there.
I just want to run away.
I've had friends that were camping and
one ran over their face while they're
sleeping.
That caring pizza.
Do you ever seen the one that kills a
pigeon?
You see the rat killing the pigeon.
This rat killed a fucking pigeon and was
killing it in front of all these people
in New York City in a park.
Look at this.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Killing the pigeons.
The pigeons alive.
The rat got ahold of the pigeon and look
how much stronger they are.
Then pigeons,
he's just carrying that poor fucking
pigeon around.
He's taking a break now who winded
fucking hard out there carrying and he's
like,
he's really trying to do the choke hold
on him.
He's killing it.
I mean,
he's a Predator like I never would have
imagined.
I never thought that rats are predators.
Yeah.
I thought of him as just being sort of
scavengers,
but this is.
This is fucking pigeons alive,
dude.
He's eating this pigeon and he's killing
it.
Drag it in a way.
Look at him.
Oh yeah.
He's taken this.
Wow.
Look at.
He's trying to get away.
Fuck you.
Pigeons.
All jacked.
Pigeons trying to get away trying.
No,
that's chasing them.
Look at that.
That is so whoever's doing the camera.
There's terrible at it.
He got it.
That's wild,
man.
He's going.
Oh,
we dropped it.
where are you going with still alive?
Yeah,
in a man.
It's fighting book.
I was writing it.
I was like,
he's got back control and said the first
time doing it,
you know he's bobbing,
killing.
He's like,
that one changed.
That'd been killing birds for a minute,
man.
He realized like,
you know what man?
Fuck cheeseburgers.
You can get your own fresh meat fresh.
Got It.
Do you know the pigeons were actually
brought in for food?
No.
That's what squad is.
When you go to a fancy restaurant and
have a squabble pigeon.
Pigeon.
Yeah.
I went to a restaurant the other day
that had squabbles it good.
I don't know.
I didn't need it.
It's probably good.
What'd you have?
I had steak instead of tried and true,
but squabbles like pigeon.
They brought them in for food that's not
as a non native bird.
Their squad.
There you go.
Little pigeon dish looks good.
Fire Grill looks good there and that
funny though,
they have to call it squad.
It's like nobody wants to eat it.
It wasn't pigeon.
Yeah.
That wouldn't sell as well.
People aren't eating pigeons.
Plug that those pigeons.
Goddamn squad farm in Los Angeles.
Back in the design.
Yeah.
All these things I think.
I believe they brought them in.
I want to say from Europe,
but I might just be guessing that.
But pitches or non native?
Yeah.
La was once home to the largest pigeon.
Fuck God.
Damn.
That's crazy.
That's near,
isn't it?
Near Dodgers Stadium,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
Christian Park.
Was it Alucien Park now?
Why are they just sitting there?
It's a painting,
but.
Oh,
is it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but why would they be sitting there?
There must be ton of feed there.
Right?
Right.
And then how do they get them throw nuts
over him at the end of the day?
I don't know when they want to eat them.
Yeah,
there was a food source.
They brought them over as a food source
from where?
Like just I guess I want to say Europe.
Yeah,
but the alligator farm.
Oh,
great assholes.
You see that they had a 14 footer and
someone's pulling in Florida.
Yeah.
Big fucking cage.
Oh Wow.
This little babies playing with
alligators.
The fuck is that 19.
Oh,
six people were just different than they
were made out of wood or hardy.
Even babies had callouses.
That is some shit that would not be done
today to leave your kid by the gator
pool.
Oh yeah.
Cool.
Normal.
We'll go have lunch.
That's not really.
Yeah,
it is.
Are.
Yeah,
California Alligator Farm Los Angeles.
If they're well fed,
you don't really have to worry about
them.
Their welfare.
They're just tired.
Just chilling all the time.
Look at that guy though.
It doesn't even look.
You're a real person.
Real fake.
It's fake.
It looks real fake.
I just think it's just shitty shitty
photography and they probably added
color to it later.
So Tommy buttons yet.
Tell me about the controversy
surrounding your use of the r word in
your last special.
Oh yeah,
it was good that that was,
that was bizarre.
It was a lot man.
It was.
Well it was also.
What I found interesting about it was
people were lying about the bit and they
were doing it in articles and they were
doing it in email campaigns.
They were lying about the content of the
bit.
There were changing what you were saying
in the bit and the.
They had to be doing it on purpose.
They definitely didn't listen to the
bit.
Yeah.
And I think it took me a while to figure
out what was,
what really was happening was that
someone,
someone's agenda or idea of what they
want to accomplish is to highlight a
campaign to eradicate saying a word and
then they had a channel to pursue by
having a comedy bit that did it,
but they could be like,
let's,
let's go after it like this.
Yeah,
but it didn't,
they didn't go.
I mean,
you know,
basically what it was funny thing is
that like the,
that joke was something that I worked
back when I did that bit backwards.
In other words,
I had the end piece of the bit,
uh,
was that while I was doing by itself,
which was a story about I saw,
I witnessed a fight in Philly,
have a white guy,
a black guy in the park,
and the white dude was screaming and
bombs and it was,
it was nuts.
So I would tell that story and then I
would,
I worked backwards into getting into the
story because I always try to figure out
like if something funny happens or
something I want to tell a story,
it's always better to figure out why are
you telling the story than just to be
like,
here's the story.
Right.
So I told the story of the,
the fight in the park.
Then I worked into,
like I figured out right before that I'm
talking about racial slurs and how,
you know,
most racial slurs are not acceptable.
And then I figured out they were like,
unless they're like white racial slurs
are totally acceptable,
like call people mix and crowds and
frogs,
polacks Guinea wipes like this whole
list of that.
And then I worked before that,
just the way into saying that was like,
why should talk about words that you
can't say that that kind of changed over
time.
Right.
So it was just like one of those jokes.
It's like,
oh,
it's helping me get into the bit,
you know.
So I,
I,
I started the bit by saying,
uh,
you can't say retarded anymore,
does the,
that's the first line of the,
of the entire bit,
which ended up being like eight or 10
minutes long.
And then people would say to me like,
to start with,
when I started getting mail about it,
they're like,
you know,
you can't say retarded.
And I go,
that's the line that I say like,
yeah,
that's the line in the joke.
But they didn't hear the bet.
He will just heard that you were doing a
bit about the word retarded once it blew
up.
Like once it got to a huge amount of,
uh,
like when it was an organized,
orchestrated campaign,
you're right,
there was people messaging me that would
say,
um,
I heard you want to kill all children
with down's.
And I'd be like,
what,
where did you see that facebook
somewhere said it.
Someone said it does have the message
messages I started to get and how many
people at the height of it sign this
petition to get you kicked off in that
floats over 100,000.
Yeah.
But here's the thing,
here's what I mean.
I don't want to portray myself as a
victim or anything,
right?
Like I,
I did a bit.
I can handle people not liking it or
liking it.
I mean,
a lot of people message me that they
were into it and I just didn't share
those because you don't want to be like,
here's someone who said they like it,
you know,
and people and people,
even people with a children and siblings
and,
uh,
with downstream messaged me,
you know,
I just didn't post those messages.
But I don't know,
I,
I'm not the victim in this whole thing
at all.
I learned,
I feel like I learned that when people
are super upset about something,
you have to let them just be upset and
be outraged if they want to be outraged,
you know,
that's,
you're right.
It,
of course it's uncomfortable to me that
you can't get out in front and be like,
Hey,
you're,
you're misrepresenting it.
Because people,
like even in the campaign language it
said like,
we want this bit taken out of the,
of the joke.
We went the trailer for the special
removed and I was like,
why?
And then I realized that the trailer has
a joke that they're confusing with the
joke where I say retarded,
like they're,
they think the two are related.
What's the one on the trailer?
The trailer is,
I say,
uh,
like some of something's funny.
Um,
disabilities are not funny,
but some are,
and it's a whole bit about obscure
things like a foreign accent syndrome
and oh,
it was hit on the head and then they
start speaking in French.
So that was the setup to that bit.
And they were,
but they were saying they were basically
making it where that setup is about
downs or something.
You know what I mean?
Like,
but they happened 40 minutes apart.
One has nothing to do with the other,
but by not it,
by just watching the trailer,
they're going,
oh see,
this is like how he's making fun of us
will.
You shouldn't even have a point where
you could say some disabilities are
funny.
Right?
You,
she can't do that.
Right?
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what I was told.
It's,
it's what it is,
is the new power that people have to
complain.
I mean people have always complained but
they haven't had the instantaneous
access to complaining and then you can
get.
And here's the thing I learned about
Kinda like mob mentality too.
That was kind of fascinating to watch.
I mean I was in it so it's different.
Once I could step back,
I realized that once you get signed to a
certain message out,
you know,
people would read the thing that says
this guy hates people with downs.
And I'm like,
what?
And that's not a hard thing to get
behind.
Oh yeah,
so then people would just,
they would sign it and I would also get
messages that said things like,
uh,
I didn't know evil like you existed in
this world,
you know,
things like that,
and I'd be like,
what,
and you're isis.
I mean,
like really crazy stuff man.
And I didn't engage nearly,
you know,
the,
the amount of people that,
that would contact me.
But I did engage a few.
I did like go back and forth with one
guy.
He was like,
he opened,
he was like,
you fucking cock sucking piece of shit.
I would stab you if I saw you on the
street.
And I go,
what's this all about?
That was my,
like my opening thing to him and he was
like,
I heard you,
uh,
you want to kill everybody with Down's
syndrome.
And I'm like,
what are you talking about men?
And then we had a back and forth about,
about the bit.
I'm like,
you should go watch it,
you know,
just watch it and then get back to me.
And then he writes me that.
He was like,
yeah,
yeah.
Sorry.
The way I spoke earlier didn't was
fucking seriously was stabbed me.
He saw me.
He would have killed me.
You'd be in jail forever.
They'd be like a defendant,
please rise.
Well,
I just dabbed Mr Herrera.
I didn't see the bits.
I didn't walk.
I didn't watch the bed.
Somebody told me it was a but at the St.
terrible things about in the now in
there and people's defense who got
upset.
Some people watched it and they're like,
I saw it.
I don't think it's horrible and I think,
you know,
I'm like,
okay.
You know?
Yeah.
But there's some people that if you just
say the word,
say the word retarded,
like that's it,
it's over.
You can't do that.
It's like so many other words.
Yeah.
But it's gotten to the point where you
don't even say the word Nigger,
like just saying it.
It's like,
Holy Shit,
what are you doing?
We'll say the n word instead of it.
Right.
And you're not even calling someone yet,
but it just acknowledging it that that's
a real word.
It's like a forbidden thing.
Well,
part of this campaign is to refer to it
as the r word,
like.
Yeah,
say it right.
You should never say it.
I mean,
it's weird,
man.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
people.
People were,
some people were very,
very upset about it and you know,
I,
I get why someone could be upset about
it.
It's not like I go like,
I don't even understand how you can be
upset.
I mean,
the natural thing I think if you're a
comic is you want to walk someone
through the joke,
but what you realize later is like
somebody who's,
who's,
who's advocating to stop saying a word
that doesn't care the details of the
joke.
I mean the joke.
Here's the other thing that sucks about
reading.
People would read transcripts.
It's like,
transcripts have no intent tone.
You know,
if you just read people's like,
I know we've talked about what your
closing on now,
which will probably close out your
special.
If you just type that out and give us
the one,
they'd be like,
you like,
you're a horrible man,
but it's in a couple of days.
It's like it's in the context of a
comedy show where there's an unspoken
agreement between performer and
audience.
It's the intent.
Like what?
How did you intend this bit to go tone?
You mean is it said satirically?
Ironically,
that bit what I'm doing in the bit is,
is basically lamenting but accepting
that words are changing,
right?
Like that's the tone of it.
The tone of it is I'm going like,
can't say retarded anymore.
That fucking sucks.
But I'm also like,
alright,
you know what I mean?
Like you're saying,
okay,
you want to do it,
and I make an example.
Like one thing that people got really
upset about it was like I said,
at the end of this bit of the retarded
part,
I say like you got now you got to be
like that.
Your idea has an extra 21st chromosome
if you asked me.
Right.
And then the next part,
the very next line that they would cut
out when people were sharing this thing
is I go like,
not the same meaning that the example
was they purposely bad example.
The joke is that if you were to say 21st
chromosome,
it's absurd.
It doesn't work like you wouldn't make
it,
but people would attack me and go like
you're telling people to start saying
that.
I'm like,
no,
I'm sharing that.
It's a bad idea.
I saw someone getting mad at someone
calling someone stupid because they were
saying that's ablest.
Do you know what a it is?
Ablest.
Oh yeah.
Because you have your of sound.
You're able.
You're able to do it.
Yeah.
Like a.
If you are mocking someone who's
diminished mentally.
Oh,
you fucking idiot.
That's ablest.
Yeah,
sure.
Which is crazy.
Yeah.
You're able bodied.
Their brain doesn't work so good.
You're an ableist if you call them
stupid.
I mean it's going to get to the point
where if you give up certain words,
I mean if we keep going like this,
it's going to get to the point where
we're just gonna have a very hard time
communicating effectively.
I totally agree.
I mean there's.
I don't know.
There's an.
Here's the thing that it is an endless
cycle.
Yeah.
I mean,
we just don't have that next
unacceptable word,
right.
You know,
like everybody knows.
I think a lot of people know that as far
as somebody who's a doesn't have is
developmentally disabled.
Retarded was kind of the Mo.
The latest term that was once acceptable
is clearly not.
Now.
That is kind of the point.
But before that,
you know,
moron was a medical term wasn't.
Yeah,
mongoloid idiot was what they used to
call 'em down syndrome children.
that was like 100 years ago was on the
birth certificate.
Right.
But I'm saying,
you know,
people who are saying,
just to stop saying return,
they're not wrong,
but there is also another word down the
pipeline,
right?
There's something else that's coming
that's going to be a medical word or
term and then that'll be used to insult
people,
but that's the way people use language.
Like once we identify this is the word
people use to label someone with a
developmental disability,
people in the slang will grow from that.
People will start using that.
Well,
what's interesting to me is that when
we're talking about words,
you're not going to change the way
people think.
So words are supposed to convey intent.
Yes.
Supposed to be sounds that we all agree
mean a certain thing and the more depth,
the more access towards you have,
the more you can sort of flavor your
conversation.
So I uNderstand what you're saying.
Like if you're saying this guy,
I kind of get it,
but you feel like this fucking guy.
I'm like,
well tom is really mad.
You know whaT I mean?
That and to take that out.
Yeah.
it's like,
I don't know.
So sometimes you take those things out
when you're like on a television show or
something like that,
but all television shows because of that
all censored television shows only
exists within a certain band.
Yes.
A certain frequency they'd never get out
of that.
Like the joey diaz frequency is like,
ah,
there's no fucking roof.
There's no fence.
Ah,
true.
This,
this frequency that you get on like late
night talk shows or a sitcom,
this very narrow band that,
that there's no concept in that band.
There's no motherfucker this,
all those things are not in there,
which is what you're all.
I feel like whenever you're.
For me,
when I'm watching something like that,
part of my Brain is always like,
go find a motherfucker somewhere.
You kind of want it.
Especially now we're,
we're just,
we're so used to being free,
especially us because a podcast and
live,
stand up,
you know,
and I was gonna bring this up like your
show,
like your show that you do with your
wife,
your mom's house.
If anybody just wanted to go cherry pick
things and write them down.
Write some of the things you guys joke
around about where you're clearly
joking,
but take it and write it down in quotes.
And then tom said to his wife,
oh yeah,
and by the way,
100,000
times worse than anything in life
stanhope ever said is set on that
podcast.
I mean,
it's not even comparable.
It's so much worse.
The content.
It's like we don't go into the show of
like,
let's be offensive,
but
we play in a no rules like have fun
environment.
You know,
it's like free flowing,
just say whatever.
And that's the fun of the show.
Yeah.
And it's also everybody knows you're
joking.
The fan base is like 100 percent on
board with this is an uncensored just
loose,
fun going for it,
going for jokes.
What I also found too is that during
this whole controversy,
after your special was released,
you got bigger.
It's like people,
they by doing that campaign and then
people who did investigate the guy
actually this guy was really fucking
funny.
I mean I got,
I usually,
you know,
again,
I never publicize these things because
it's gross,
you know,
to be like check out this compliment or
whatever.
But like I got so manY messages from
people who are like,
I saw this thing on the news because it
was on a lot of local news that there's
a controversial netflix thing out.
People would message me and I saw this
thing so I decided to check you out.
new fan,
just bought tickets to see you at blah
blah blah.
So I started to get a bunch of messages
like that for sure,
because you're going to get 30 percent
of the people that aren't even going to
read it,
they're just going to call you piece of
shit,
but the other people are going to go,
what is going on over here?
And then next thing you know they're
going to investigate and they got to go
what?
They're doing.
This guy dirty.
Yeah.
And then boom,
I got a lot of.
I got a lot of support that I never.
Like I said,
I never made light of the fact that
people were being supportive,
but people were being very supportive.
Well,
it just seems like there,
there's different,
there's different rules now for standup
and you got to really cover your ass.
But in your case you did cover your ass
and they disingenuously left that part
out.
Like they deceptively left that out when
they were writing down what you had
said.
He didn't put it in the context.
That's true.
And uh,
and then,
you know,
part of you goes a man,
like I'm not trying to paint myself as a
martyr or you know what I mean,
and like people who are going down this
path of,
you know,
they have family or friends with a
disability.
It's like I'm not gonna my whole thing
was never to attack them,
so I'm not going to try to make it a
battle that I have to win.
So once,
once I saw like kind of what I thought
clearly was happening,
I was like,
you know,
just let people vent their frustration
about if it's about me or about what I
said,
just let it happen.
And um,
you know,
because I don't,
I don't hold it against them that
they're,
that they have that they're upset about
this issue,
you know?
And even though like you're saying your
instinct is,
is wants to go like,
hold on,
why don't you put it clearly.
RighT.
I said,
after a moment of it,
I realized that that wasn't the point
for me in that,
in that time I was like,
just let people.
Because I also figured out that if
people,
yeah,
a lot of people were going to read it,
say something and go like,
this guy's fucking worst and it's kind
of feels good.
Sometimes it'd be like,
you want to know who the bad guy is,
this guy and I,
you know,
even though you want to be like,
hey,
I'm not that bad of a guy a.
If someone wants to just go there,
you just kind of have to let it go and
then let the people who were enjoying it
or who were investigating it and finding
like,
oh,
it's a little different than it's being
presented.
Yeah,
discovery.
That one.
There's so many outlets that are looking
for outrageous stories.
Yeah,
that's true.
More than ever.
And recreational outlet age,
recreational outrage.
Peddlers or like an an all time high and
there's so many people out there that
are working.
The journalists,
the writers they work in for these
websites and they got to produce
content.
Man,
I got to tell you,
the one of the most amazing discoveries
of that process is not the people who
got upset at me and would start whatever
emailing,
saying pam saying things.
It was the reporters who would do these
news pieces and also not familiar with
what they were reporting.
They don't care.
I don't send that kind of make.
I mean doesn't that kind of stand out to
you?
Like you'Re gonna you're going to do a
piece on television that you report to?
I don't know how many people.
And you're not familiar.
You can tell that they had not even
watched the clip.
Yeah,
and they're doing.
It wasn't like a,
just an anchor reading copy.
It was the person doing the piece aBout
It.
Had no idea what they were talking
about.
Yeah,
they're lazy,
super lazy.
There's a lot of bad shit out there just
to.
People just barely just phone it in
barely paying attention to what they're
doing and then pretending that they're
on the moral high ground.
Yeah.
You got to like.
But I think it's kind of a challenge too
because it forces me to like really
cover all my bases and in these bits.
Yeah.
Like I did that with the bruce jenner
bit from last year.
Like I was trying to figure out a way to
make fun of this.
I'm like,
what is the best way to make fun of it?
Well,
the parallel to my own life that have
never been more of a bitch.
I've never been happier.
But I live with all girls and I'm never
been more of a bitch.
I just given everything around me all
the time.
Sure.
And that I'm not going out like bruce
jenner,
that I've never been more of a bitch in
my life.
But I'm not going out like that is
people like,
oh,
he's always been a man that's really a
woman,
a woman trapped in a man's body.
I'm like,
maybe,
or maybe if you live with crazy bitches
long enough,
you fucking become one maybe.
Did you get a lot of for that?
You had to get some right?
None.
I skated through that one as well
because i.
First of all,
I caught it right when people were
annoyed.
Yeah,
right.
When people are like,
okay,
enough of this,
like I rode.
The timing was really good.
Like when it came out,
it's like people like enough the fucking
articles and she's pretending she's
beautiful and she's amazing and stopped.
Stopped.
What about the fact she killed somebody?
What about the ones to.
Kyle does.
Kyle does a whole bit.
Find kyle's bit.
It's him at the wheel.
It's a.
It's caitlin at the wheel.
Yeah.
And uh,
he got recognizing jura bruce brewster
to caitlyn gets off free.
Play this.
I just got my driver's license back,
man.
Man,
bro.
Fuck me when he killed that lady with
the chicago right now.
Carolyn's got a clean record,
but I'm a much better driver then broke
off.
Don't be afraid to hit the streets.
Retarded kid.
I'm bike.
Oh yeah.
There you go.
Tied everything together.
That was the lower one with todd.
What's trump?
Who's that?
With trump in the corner with the girl.
I be stormy,
right?
Hi danny.
It's stormy.
Danielle darby.
Why are you calling me here?
Because I can't stop thinking about our
night.
They gather more hard.
A nobody but you like nine slash 11 to
my athol ground.
Zero a meth.
But all I know about.
I haven't had go.
Don't call here again late.
I was going to tell you a bang.
Make it quick.
You have gonorrhea,
syphilis and super aids.
Face that face that he chose to.
It's such a perfect face for trump.
Oh my god.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
Well kudos to netflix for the way they
handled it because they just stepped
back and just let it.
Let it.
Let the fucking erase washover.
Let the fire go out.
I kinda took,
I took cues from that after a minute
because at first I was like,
I should fucking talk to people.
And then I kinda was like,
I'm just waiting for someone to kilo
hooker,
someone's gonna to do something to take
over in the news.
Now I got 20 minutes out of it too.
So that word.
Oh,
that's.
There you go.
I feel like you have to address
something like that.
Oh yeah.
Why wouldn't do two chapels?
Got a bunch of shit.
It is new special about some shit that
he got in trouble with his old special.
I'm hoping it goes,
goes this way.
It's.
I mean,
you know the audit.
Here's the thing.
When I do a show now,
the audience is so aware of that stuff.
Oh yeah.
That it's like,
it would be disingenuous for me to not
mention it,
you know?
Yeah.
That becomes a thing,
right?
The more stand up you're doing,
the more people know what you're doing
and then when something goes sideways,
that becomes a bit.
Yeah,
of course you're feeding off yourself.
yeah,
yeah.
that's true.
I mean,
I just say Louisiana and is like,
ah,
that's right.
The Louisiana,
they put.
That was the thing.
People get mad at you for real pissed
off a whole state.
A whole state.
People were saying that they were saving
up bail money.
What?
I've never even.
I know,
it's like when I saw that,
yeah,
they're like,
I would see comments like we got to
start saving our bail money because
we're going to go fuck up thompson girl
and then we can bail out.
I'm like,
you're saving up for that.
It's one of the most white trash,
fucking amazing,
shitty things I've ever heard.
So a savings account for bail.
what did you do about security after
that?
Um,
I had to take some.
They,
like I was,
it was recommended to me by a whole
bunch of industry people to take
security precautions in Louisiana.
That's it.
They're just like,
well you sold out like crazy and
Louisiana nine months in advance.
So you haven't even gotten there yet?
No,
no.
Yeah,
iT sold out.
We added.
Yeah,
it's going to be all dudes in the,
in the audience going like this.
Yeah.
I'm like,
you're kidding.
That money to attack.
That'd be hilarious if feel like we paid
you to fucking just certain states.
Yeah.
I've been shitting on Connecticut for
years and we've had low back.
You're shitting on Connecticut.
Gets to meet people come up to me and
they're like,
I'm talking like in a coffee shop
somewhere.
Be like,
why does joe hey kinetic,
I don't really hate Connecticut.
One of my best friends lives in
Connecticut.
Shout out to tommy junior,
don't really hate Connecticut.
I'm talking shit,
you got to understand,
and by the way,
if you get like real sensitive about
your state,
it might be a fucking idiot stop.
It's a patch of dirt.
There's no real estate.
There's lines arbitrarily drawn in the
sand.
You just drive near clock across this
line.
Now you're in Massachusetts.
Does that make any sense to you?
Well,
no.
And the other thing is,
you know what helps you see that clearly
you've had this.
I know I had this for sure is moving.
When you move a bunch of times in your
life,
you're like,
oh yeah,
like why?
Why would you be married in love to that
patch of land would never move.
They feel like a certain tie to that
place and they don't.
They're more sensitive.
Like I've lived in Ohio,
Minnesota,
Wisconsin,
dc,
Maryland,
Florida,
Massachusetts and California and anytime
I've mentioned any one of those places,
somebody somewhere has been like,
that place fucking sucks.
I'm like,
okay,
sure.
Go ahead.
But like your birthplace,
sex,
fine.
I don't care man.
It's just a place that I was squeezed
out of someone's vagina.
I don't care.
Yeah,
you moved around a lot.
You get it.
Yeah.
It's like,
why would you be so like people take it
like you're insulting their family,
you know,
it is my family.
No,
it's not.
do you know where they,
the nuttiest about it?
Texas main.
Oh really?
They call them maniacs.
Really?
Yup.
I was doing gigs up in Maine and I was
shitting on main and this guy was this
old guy literally got up and he was
blood in his eyes coming towards the
stage screaming at me.
Yeah.
I had this whole bit
about how if you get pulled over that I
got a speeding ticket when I was driving
because it's like there's this long
stretch from portland and bangor.
It's like an hour drive where there's
nothing on the road.
And I go,
I got a speeding ticket because they
just,
you know,
you can't help yourself.
I go,
but you got to figure like the cops from
Maine,
you should be able to trick them.
And I had this whole bit about trick the
cop really fucking stupid copy,
throw a potato out the window with the
potato go.
That's a pretty good one,
nice and round and the guy drives off
and while I'm in the middle of doing
this,
guy jumps up and he's screaming,
just screaming at me,
fuck you.
Fucking main is the best package date.
You're a piece of shit,
and he's really,
really mad at me and I couldn't believe
it.
I was like,
do you really mad?
And someone's making fun of Maine.
he's going to be mad,
but I always think someone's got to be
mad about something else.
Right.
That's their turf.
They're defending their turf.
That's right.
Yeah.
That's their spot.
They call them maniacs.
Yeah.
They get really,
really,
really angry.
It's funny people,
but people who have audiences will like,
if you like you,
people are nuts.
If you're like,
you're crazy people.
They're like,
that's cool.
I like that.
It was certain places like Texas is
Texas.
Yeah.
I have a bit that I opened with in Texas
all the time about this one spot in
Texas.
It's like it's.
It defines Texas pete,
like you ever seen.
You know what a buckeys is?
[inaudible]?
No.
Yeah.
This whole bit about buckets,
not like a gas station,
kind of.
It's like a gas station.
If you created a gas station while you
were in the middle of a cocaine binge
and someone said,
dude,
I want you to make me the ultimate
guide.
That's true.
It's fucking crazy pLace,
but it's so light and when you bring it
up to texans,
they get all excited.
They get excited.
Yes.
It's like,
yeah,
this is something that defined.
That's a buckeys later that lose size of
that place doesn't even make sense.
No,
that's 100 pumps.
Easy.
Yeah.
You get 100 people pulling over for gas.
That's crazy.
I mean,
they're just all prepped for the end of
the world.
There are stretches.
This is how dumb I am of a I 10 in Texas
that you will hit maybe like 75 miles
without gas and you tempt fate,
you know,
if you're driving,
that's not good.
No,
and twice I've been like,
eh,
I'll get it.
The next one.
And almost been just fumes.
You know,
somebody did it in a tesla,
died out.
he died out of out driving with a tesla.
Good luck.
Some farmer pulls over seas.
You have your shitty electric scooter.
doesn't want to work anymore.
I read the elon musk is sleeping on the
floor of the tesla factory.
They said he's sleeping on the floor of
the tesla factory where they're trying
to get production ready.
Uhm,
and that tesla's finally going to leave
this eli musk is stressed.
oh son of a bitch.
Elon musk is stressed.
Says he's sleeping on the tesla factory
floor and has no time to go home and
shower.
Wow.
That guy's an animal.
He really is.
Has there ever been a guy who does more
shit?
Benjamin franklin?
Nah,
but asshole with a kite and key.
Fuck,
that guy wouldn't teeth.
Now what he's done,
think of is he's in the middle of making
this boring company that bores holes
under the ground and then they'll have
the high speed train speed train.
Yeah.
He's in the middle of the hyperloop.
He's in the middle of space x.
He's in the middle of tesla production.
They got approved for those satellites
to go in the space for the internet that
didn't hear about that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
At least can provide worldwide internet.
Right?
That's the idea.
Yeah,
dude.
Yeah.
It says,
how does one has one guy able to do so
much?
It's a better.
Now the crazy thing.
I was saying the other day,
he's so smart that people just let them
drill under the ground in la.
They're like,
yeah,
go ahead.
Go ahead man.
Nobody else like,
who the fuck would let anybody just
drill into the ground?
Who do you.
Where do you,
what office do you walk into with that
presentation?
You know,
it's like people,
it's like a six month thing to build a
fence in la.
He was like,
nice to go down a bunch like way far and
then make trains.
They would never listened to him if he
was like a regular person know or even
regular genius.
Like you almost have to be like elon
musk.
He's like our.
It's like a guy and tips.
He's like our guy,
you know,
elon musk,
plan for high speed car tunnel,
gets initial approvals from la.
I would like to see the documentary
about the presentation.
I'd like to see what happens when the
earthquake kits and that thing fills up
with water rushing towards you and
you're on that scooter.
God damn.
Two point seven mile proof of concept
puddle along alongside polenta.
Damn.
Zero missions.
High speed underground alternative means
of transit for personal vehicles and
slash or single rider use according to
urbanize which reported on the approval
man.
I mean,
what,
what motivates a guy like that to do so
many different things.
That's what's so confusing.
It's,
it's,
um,
it really is that real curious.
He's an engineer at heart and it's that.
See,
I think it's the curiosity and,
uh,
of,
of the challenge and accomplishing
something that hasn't been done before
and I want to make it possible.
I feel like that has to be the real
drive.
It can't be the money and the,
the,
the stardom of it.
I feel like he really gets off on how
can I find a solution to this thing?
Yeah,
well they're all technologically based
things.
Everything he's doing is like tesla,
the tesla,
those home units,
the tiles,
the solar tiles that he's putting on
people's roofs and also it all ties into
better for humanity.
Yeah.
It was amazing.
Yeah,
he's an,
he's an incredibly lucky that we got a
guy like that.
I mean he's,
he's essentially like our version
of a tesla.
Nikola tesla guy just keeps coming up
with new crazier shit to just.
It's amazing.
there's only one of those guys though.
That's crazy.
Of course.
The other ones like you would think
there'd be a bunch of those kind of guys
now he's.
Yeah.
What if he wasn't born?
You know what I mean?
Like when,
when you have a guy who's that much of
an outlier,
it's just so it's so strange because
you're forced to consider like how,
how is kind of creePy and a nation of
300,
20 million people,
that one individual be such an outlier,
but even I would even outside of that,
there's not even someone like really
liked him somewhere else.
So it's really like,
no,
like 7 billion people.
Yeah.
Who is,
who is the one person that you think of
when it comes to technological
innovation and and producing crazy new
inventions and using them to the public
of jobs like that.
Right.
I mean it Was sorta,
sorta.
He didn't do it the way that this guy
does know.
He was just within my company is new
shit you're going to want.
Yeah.
That was really him.
It's crazy.
You see so much.
So many people talking shit about apple
lately,
but their laptops,
people are just tired of.
I'm tired of the lack of innovation.
It's just all the same thing.
All the mac books look the same but by a
windows laptop you by infinite variety,
bunch of different types and styles and
macbook air.
Thirteen inch or 15 inch macbook pro was
considered kind of a dud I think,
and I know that sucks.
Home pod didn't sell well.
They thought that it was going to be a
big thing.
Well that's the thing where it's like
you only have so much momentum.
That's by jobs and then the new guy tim
cook has to takeover and he's got to
figure out a way to keep that thing
rolling and it's just,
he's not the same guy.
it seems like way healthier.
Right,
right.
He's not,
I mean healthier,
not just physically,
but mentally.
He's not.
He's not obsessed,
man,
you know?
Yeah.
Because jobs was obsessed.
You need to be obsessed to be that guy.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's probably one of the things that
made them sick.
what was your take on it and you know,
you've probably already talked about it,
so sorry if you did,
but uh,
with that whole connor in New York thing
pretty fucking crazy.
Um,
there's a whole story behind it.
And the story behind it is that artem
low bob,
who is one of connor stablemates,
had an issue with khabib number go
madoff because he said something in an
interview that could be pulled out of
fights and the conners,
the real real fighter,
and then khabib's a coward,
so could be found him and kind of
smacked him a little.
Said you'd call me a coward,
motherfucker like that kind of shit,
and there's a video of him saying it to
them,
talking to them in russian and connor
saw that video and flew from Ireland
with a bunch of fucking gangsters all
the way to New York to crazy.
Yeah.
There might've been some substances
involved.
Not good though.
No.
I mean he might.
He literally might wind up wind up in
jail.
It's entirely possible that new york's
going to prosecute him.
I mean that was like a salt.
he threw a dolly at a car.
People get their eyes cut their face
cut.
Glass shatter,
right?
Yeah.
And luckily it wasn't.
I mean,
I don't want to Say it any better that
men get cut,
but imagine if he did it to rose.
Nama.
Eunice,
she's beautiful little 24 year old girl
who's a world champion would have.
she got cut by the glass.
What if he ruined her career?
Like what if she never got to fight
again with the glass?
Cut her eye and we lost rose and that
would've been the day of or day before a
fight.
Before a fight.
She,
she thought about pulling out of the
fight.
She was so distraught by the whole event
that she really pulling out.
Yeah,
because she was on that bus.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
definitely not going to get them.
I guess I don't know it,
but then in a way it does.
I know there's people who are talking
about,
oh,
this is all coordinated planned like
teams on your rent press thing.
Yeah.
I mean you can definitely see how,
how it could be.
It's not.
It doesn't,
but I mean,
yeah,
it's just not.
But it.
It's not gonna is it gonna lower his
draw.
Probably gonna.
He's gonna be even bigger than ever.
That's what I'm saying.
So when he actually does fight khabib,
if those to do fight,
if let's say,
let's say they solve everything civilly,
meaning connor pays everybody off,
pays off,
pays ray borg off.
Pays off emotional duress to anyone who
sues him.
That was on the bus.
PaY some sort of a fine to the state of
New York.
That'S pretty significant.
Gives up a few million dollars for sure.
Right?
Then they put the fight together.
It's going to be giant.
Maybe that would be the rule.
Conor mcgregor's comeback fight as
already being mooted as.
What does that mean as the biggest
record breaker in ufc history?
I've never seen that word.
Mu did.
Have you ever seen it?
I think it means touted it,
but never seen it either.
The biggest record breaker in ufc
history.
Yeah.
I will be.
If he fights khabib.
Experts are predicting.
He'll be back in the octagon within a
year.
Okay.
I'd say a year from now,
that's not a like a much of a stretch.
That's a crazy prediction of six to 12
months to.
I just saw and maybe 81,000
seat stadium in moscow.
That's what they're gonna do
potentially.
I mean it's not signed obviously,
but that's what this article is going to
be right here.
Watching right here,
watching that shit on that tv.
It's going to be awesome.
We're going to be in american on
american soil drinking,
budweiser,
drinking american beer.
Maybe some sam adams,
so I'm american.
I'm not going to.
Russia not going.
Come to me and Russia cut to you in
Russia.
Got to,
you mean the ufc?
They sit down and get me excited about
it.
And how many hours is the flight?
Shit?
It's a long flight.
Yeah.
It just seems like a.
do a show there?
Nope.
No,
I really want to stay here.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't.
The,
the beat up that you get from
international travel.
Yeah.
It's not worth it and quite honestly I
like doing fight companions as much or
more than I like actually being at the
fights.
Really?
Oh yeah.
It's the most fun ever.
when me and brendan and eddie and brian
get together and just talk shit and get
high and start drinking wine and just
getting silly.
Sometimes we barely comment on the
fights.
It's just like being silly.
he's having a good time.
Eddie have some new conspiracy theory
about whatever and eddie will go off and
want to hear that new dinosaurs not
being real or there's always something.
I mean he just never gives up.
He loves him the fuck.
I mean,
he left and then every now and then
there's something that comes out that
sort of confirms it.
Like,
did you see that sinclair broadcasting
network compilation?
Yes.
Which shows all the different anchors,
same exact same thing,
and you realize,
oh,
they were given a script all across the
country.
All these local news places.
We're giving a script to try to chastise
fake news and say we have to be careful
about fake news.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
It's weird.
[inaudible] and they're growing.
They're growing.
Sinclair's growing a lot.
Yeah,
they have.
There's know studies show to that.
I guess one of the biggest opinion
formers still a that people kind of
write off because it's not as sexy and
big as local news.
Local news is huge at at forming
opinions,
which I believe it.
Yeah,
I believe it.
It's.
It's so fascinating to me.
And then this facebook thing is
fascinating to me too,
because we were talking about facebook
yesterday that what we were watching
this,
you know,
when he was being grilled zuckerberg.
Yeah.
One of the things they were talking
about his upcoming elections
internationally.
He's talking about how facebook has
really,
you know,
we have to concentrate and all these
upcoming elections and make sure there's
no bad actors that are like what?
Like facebook is involved in shaping the
world.
It'S incredible.
Yeah.
I,
you see,
I saw an article about how they said
that these senators that grilled him
miss so many things,
basically because they're old,
they're just like,
they didn't ask so many questions
because they don't understand how
facebook works.
There's a funny video that I put up,
jamie,
you find it,
it's on twitter of some of the more
hilarious things that came out of that
interaction and one of them was the guy
asks a zuckerberg,
would you tell us the hotel you're
staying at?
He's like,
no,
like,
would you be willing to tell us and show
us all the messages,
all the that you've sent?
And he's like,
no,
like,
listen to this.
I'Ll get to that part,
those,
this,
uh,
back up,
back it up.
That's nine fertilizer or campaign,
uh,
who,
who asks for it?
Mr zuckerberg,
would you be comfortable sharing with us
the name of the hotel you stayed in last
night?
Uh,
no.
If you've messaged anybody this week,
would you share with us the names of the
people you've messaged?
Senator?
No,
I would probably not choose to do that
publicly here.
I think
maybe what this is all about,
here's what everybody's been trying to
tell you.
That,
and I,
I say this gently,
your user agreement shocks.
I'm going to suggest to you that you go
back home and rewrite it until you're
$1,200
an hour lawyers.
No disrespect,
they're good,
but,
but tell hIm you want it written in
english and swahili so the average
american can understand that would be a
start quite a story,
right?
There's no competition.
That's what's really weird.
Yeah.
Like as far as like,
there's twitter.
Yeah,
that is just,
it's cool that we have these three
different ones too,
which is really fascinating.
You got twitter,
which is just some text,
like I saw this article,
check it out and then people retweet it.
I liked that aspect of the product.
And then,
you know,
you could state your opinion on things,
you could clarify things,
but then there is instagram,
just photos,
hey,
this is my time in Peru,
look at the beautiful buildings.
They own that one,
that's not a competitor.
Right.
But I mean the three different things.
And then there's facebook,
which is like a lot of arguments in
discussions,
deep discussion,
politics.
That's like the big one when it comes to
like deep political discussions.
It's a wonder what is coming next
because these we typically people try to
my goals,
I know you're right.
But I feel like,
I don't know,
they have a,
they have a pretty strong grip.
I mean,
you know,
snapchat is really popular,
but as soon as snapchat looked like it
was about to just really explode an
meaning that it would be the kind of
premier,
you know,
a visual one.
Instagram was like,
we're going to add that that same,
uh,
aspect to instagram,
instagram stories just squashed that
squashed.
Instagram's a better platform.
But it's just really interesting to see
like what we choose to put our time and
our energy and where it's going.
And when Is the first virtual reality or
augmented reality,
social network going to what's got to be
around the corner?
They must be scrambling to be the first
to come up with it.
Because if you can like if you tried,
there was a thing called views.
There still is a Thing called views.
I got on it.
I told them once people get on it,
I haven't even opened it and fucking
month if you put a cup v use,
I put a couple pictures up and then I
was like,
I gave up.
I mean I signed up for it but I can't do
another one right now.
I just can't see.
I don't even know what it's called.
The,
I forgot his fucking name.
Nobody's on that goddamn thing.
But it was also confusing,
like no one could comment on my pictures
and less like accepted them.
And then I looked at thirtY 5,000
people to accept.
I'm not doing that.
I gotta do one by one.
I don't know.
It seemed like it.
Put them in groups.
Oh come all the way off.
Fuck off with that gap all the way.
Fuck outta here wIth that.
Am I going to do that?
How am I going to do that with 35,000
people?
IT might even be more than that now.
I don't even know how many I have now.
tell me how many I have.
I haven't been there in forever.
I don't even know the name of it.
Kona views veered so far off.
Google views.
It's hard to figure out how to look to.
What's Your.
Have a favorite one?
You have a favorite platform or like
instagram added to it seems to be the,
the most.
Uh,
It's the,
it's the most flexible.
You can put text up,
you can put an image of text,
you can put a video up.
It's great.
You know,
I think it's the most flexible.
You're fucking instagram makes me
hungry.
Yeah.
Do you cook?
I do not got some milk.
I just got some new sausages.
It's very easy.
Easy to cook.
Elk sausage.
I have some.
Oh yeah.
Tommy?
Yes.
Fuck yeah,
there's some here.
Yes,
I do.
Oh,
can I take some reserve?
Oh shit.
Oh,
it does hurt stocks.
Doxil I.
This is a good year.
Good year for the rogan meet.
Collecting from.
Yeah.
I got to elk this year,
so that's like 800 pounds of meat.
I've already given away a couple of
hundred pounds.
Really?
Yeah,
I'd give it away for everybody.
That's awesome.
I love it.
I feel like I'm a provider.
Yeah,
you are like give it to people and then
they send me pictures of food.
They cooked.
I'm like,
you're the village elder man.
You're fucking.
Duncan sent me a picture of these
meatballs and he made with the elk,
with the ground elk.
I waS like,
oh my god,
that looks so good.
That was crazy.
Duncan obviously.
Very good.
I saw him last night.
Yeah,
last night.
He's here.
Yeah,
he's back.
He's back.
move back.
He's great man.
He's such a good dude.
He is a sweetheart.
We did brooklyn together.
Me,
him and ari.
Oh really?
I didn't.
Yeah,
it was fun,
man.
And then we went to peter luger's.
I saw the Peter Lynch.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
You know,
they put those.
I think it's the second part of it.
They have like a process there that they
put in at 1200 degree broiler,
so like that's why it pops.
This shits that.
By the way,
I think obviously peter luger does it
right.
To me it's one of the only.
I'm not somebody that
complains at restaurants.
Yeah,
come on.
I was camp.
It was a beautiful.
Those are beautiful.
You don't get that over a plate of
carrots.
I don't.
I like fuck it.
I can
meet piping hot.
I can't do luke warm,
you know,
it's like I'll,
I'll tell them,
can you make it hotter?
And they're like,
you want hot sauce?
And I'm like,
no,
no.
And you put it back on fire so that it's
hot when I eat it.
That's the only way you like it.
I like meat.
I like it.
Particularly steak,
like temperature wise,
very high.
I don't like it cooked through,
but I liked it like on a hot plate or
just like off the grill in my mouth.
That's interesting because some people
think that you should let it rest.
I know letting it rest before you.
I mean,
you know,
taking,
letting them eat rest before you grill
it and.
No,
no.
Letting it rest after your grill.
It supposed to let it rest for 10
minutes now.
Fuck that.
No way.
No.
Yeah,
there's all sorts of weird rules.
What you're supposed to do and not
supposed to do with meat.
I watched the whole steg documentary.
Which one?
I think it might be called steak or was
it just followed like all over the
world.
Different people who either are chefs or
raise cattle and,
and you know,
theories on how to make that.
This might be it here.
Yeah.
This is it.
I watched this.
Is it good?
It was a production wise is a little
[inaudible] but we will do shit
different ways.
Yeah,
I mean,
but it's,
it's entertaining and you know,
seeing how they make it different in
different parts of the world was cool.
You could go down a rabbit hole when it
comes to food preparation.
Oh yeah.
You know,
like anthony bourdain show,
no reservations got me into it and now
his new show parts unknown is fucking
amazing for that.
Yeah.
Just traveling everywhere and eating
exotic food everywhere.
It's great.
I love bordain.
You know,
he's all skinny now.
Have you seen him?
Yeah,
he looks carves out.
Did he cut out the booze?
Cut out the car.
He has that naturally thin frame to
never was really like a big,
big guy.
Now he does jujitsu every day.
He's shredded to izzy.
It's got a six pack full on six pack.
He used to have a pot belly.
Good for you,
ant?
Yeah,
that's nice man.
Pimping pimping.
He used to like,
used to have like a pot belly just
eating.
He told me that he got on statens which
are um,
those uh,
cholesterol blockers,
you know,
he got on those instead of not,
instead of changing his diet,
just like,
fuck it,
I'm just gonna get on the statens.
I'm just gonna keep you may.
His whole show was just.
I mean,
I'd like to,
for him to do an episode just on
diarrhea and where he's headed and what
the worst one was because I'm sure he's
got some epic stories.
Almost shit my pants last night at the
improv.
Really?
Yup.
I came so close,
same in my car,
I'm on my way to the improv.
I was coming over the hill and I was on
laurel and I was like,
oh my god,
I'm
several miles away and I'm not going to
make it real and I was going to try to
get into the mcdonald's on sunset and
take a shit there.
And I was like,
if I just get into that mcdonald,
but then I'm like,
I'm gonna have to buy something because
this is all a lot of homeless people in
that area.
You can't just use the bathroom,
you have to be a customer.
I kind of have the time and I'm like,
I'm just going to keep it together.
And it was just sweating,
willpower alone that I didn't shit
myself.
It was an internal wrestling.
Did you park in front or did you parked
right in front and I ran into the
bathroom and I got to the toilet,
got my pants down,
put my butt and then my shit so hard.
I lifted like,
yeah,
it's like one of those jet things with
the dudes and the ocean and the water.
The jets like got him up in the air,
a jet pack,
like drag racing when the foot hit the
gas money cars front.
Oh,
I barely made it and I miss my spot.
Were you scared someone was going to be
on the toilet?
Did mr highspot?
Yeah,
nikki glaser.
I'd take my spot when I went after.
What did beforehand?
Nothing unusual.
It's just,
it didn't make any sense.
I don't know what it was.
I don't know what got me,
but something got me and it got and it
was like,
it was like on the way,
on the way over the hill.
I was like,
oh no,
like I'm not gonna make it.
And I was,
I was,
you know,
you start thinking of different places
you could pull over to shit.
Like maybe if I just jumped in this
guy's bushes,
like maybe I was trying to think of
places where I could.
Shit.
That's how bad acadian.
Yeah,
on laurel worse.
I was thinking of pulling over on a side
street and just shitting in some bushes.
It's just the cleanup it because
yesterday I'm thinking now because I
know now I know this is a possibility.
I didn't shit myself,
but I came close close.
I need an extra pair of underwear and
pants in my car at all times.
Yeah.
It's a small package.
Pair of pants or underwear.
Maybe not totally paper to maybe.
Maybe it goes,
goes low.
Where was callin going when he said he
shit himself?
Didn't.
He didn't.
He said he did and then he showed up and
I'm like,
what happened?
Oh,
it changed.
My parents were like,
what?
You just changed your payment?
Changes their pants.
Just change your pants.
Do you just pull it?
Where'd you change your pants?
Where?
Where'd you go with your shitty pants?
Did you go to a gas station?
What the fuck are you talking about,
calvin?
Yeah.
No,
he was supposed to be doing a spot at
the ice house.
That god can't make it a shit mY pants.
Like your people waiting for you here.
Get over here.
Twenty minutes later he's there.
No shit.
Fresh pAnts,
son of a bitch.
I hate shooting at clubs.
You got to do what you gotta do though.
Of course.
I know I'm saying that.
I mean I've done it.
Yeah.
He shouldn't have planes too and I
fucking sometimes god dammit.
Yeah.
Planes are the worst when you go in
there after someone shit and all that
smear as over the log smear over the
inside of that bowl.
That's a very ineffective way of
containing odor and cleaning the.
I've seen it.
I've
walked into a plane bathroom like get.
Oh my god.
You lift up the seat and it's stuck to
the side and put like a chunk.
Oh,
log.
Yeah.
And then you hit flush and you see the
water go over it.
Just like not moving it at all.
You got to pee on it and knock it loose
and sometimes you don't even have enough
strength for that.
I've,
I've told the flight attendants and
someone really dropped a crazy shit in
there.
They gave me spray like from their
personal,
like go spray that in there myself.
It's not going to shake it loose off the
side.
No,
it's a clear.
Yeah.
It's intense.
Intense man.
Yeah.
Why is,
why is your body have to smell so awful,
like wouldn't know.
What purpose does that serve,
I guess to let you know that that is not
something you want to put in your body.
You don't want to eat that,
you know,
because otherwise,
like I told you about my dog when he was
a puppy,
he would eat his shit.
He wants you to show up so bad that as
he was shitty,
he will be turning around and trying to
bite it out of his apple.
Oh my god.
Really?
This little golden retriever.
Wow.
Was when he was a little baby.
He would do that.
It was hilarious and disgusting at the
same time,
but he'd be like shitting and they'd go,
oh,
what do we got here?
And then they apparently they,
they,
they such a common thing with dogs.
There's something to give them,
you know,
to,
to keep,
to make their shit tastes like,
oh,
it's not a terrible enough on this shit
isn't.
And they're like,
no,
this will really make it bad.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Some people spray something on the shit.
I'm like,
why don't you just clean it up?
You lazy bitch can just claim it.
Hang up the phone.
I'm just going to spray something.
We'll spray some hot sauce.
Teach a little fellow.
Wasn't,
you know,
I watched this thing on spies and they
used to,
uh,
they used to leave notes like,
this is back in the cold war,
days in dead animals.
And like that would be one way to pass
on information,
but those animals would get eaten by
other animals because it's dead,
right?
So then they,
they figured out that nothing.
No wild animal basically likes tabasco.
So they would douse dead animals with
tabasco and have a note.
Wow.
Tucked into it.
Never get eaten.
They would smell that and be like,
fuck that.
Isn't that crazy?
You'd be like,
hmm.
That was pretty good.
This might be doable.
Now,
when I was in new orleans,
they have hot chicken,
fried chicken dipped in hot sauce.
Yeah.
I think in nashville has a nashville,
new orleans,
nashville,
the nashville hot chicken is confused
it.
Yeah,
I confused it.
It's nashville.
It was fucking amazing.
Amazing,
right?
Yeah.
There's a big one here I think downtown.
Yep.
What is it not ready?
Just one North Carolina.
Was that one of those ones?
You have to wait in line all day.
But that's the nashville one too,
which makes me.
I'm like,
fuck this,
I only make a certain amount of day.
Yeah.
So they don't like,
they're not cooking it all day.
They make one batch and that's how much
you get.
Let that kind of demand for your,
like a made this and they're like,
we'll
wait outside in the sun.
Please.
Can I have some like I'm out,
I'm leaving,
I'm leaving for the day.
I'll see you.
The franklins and austin franklin's
barbecue.
Famous for that.
They people pay people to wait in line
for them and here.
Um,
I mean I've driven by it.
I mean for years.
What's it called?
On the brayer.
Pinks.
Yeah.
You see that line sometimes you're like,
that's just a regular hot dog to get mad
once you eat it.
Yeah,
of course.
I'm a fucking moron.
And in philly,
almost all the good cheese steak places
have a crazy line.
Well there's something about booze.
And then food that's cooked out in the
open,
you're like,
ah,
that,
that smell fly around the.
The night air.
Yeah.
The last time I drank a of substance,
I think it was in columbus,
and they have a carts,
street carts guys making,
you know,
uh,
euros and hot dogs.
And like,
you have a little booze and you,
you tear it down and you're like,
that was good.
Round two,
let's do it.
And then it's like 10 minutes after you
eat your second thing when you're
drinking,
you're like,
this was a bad idea.
I should have just stuck to the one we
were in columbus once and we went to a
bar after we did the comedy show and
there was a guy in front of the bar that
was selling venison sausage sandwiches
with peppers and onions and whole lease
shit.
Was it good?
I felt like the first time I'd ever
eaten a venison sausage,
but this guy killed the deer himself.
Was selling venison sausages.
Had a cart and the cart.
Yeah.
That's the coolest fucking amazing.
And all kinds of crazy sauces that he
was putting on him as an artist.
I think about that.
That's an artist.
Just I hope one day I walk out.
There he is.
Yeah.
The venison sausage guy.
I got some elk sausage for you telling
me about them.
I can't wait.
I can't.
Let's wrap this up because I gotta get
outta here.
I gotta drive all the way to fucking
irvine tonight.
I was gonna ask you if tom could tell
you about the cursive little b.
He knows all about it.
Yeah.
I think you know more about the curse of
little b.
Little b.
He really did curse Kevin Duran,
right?
He did carson and it works.
Kevin wants.
No,
no part of that.
Wow.
I mean,
not even apologize now,
but kevin switched teams because of the
curse.
Who knows?
He said he was never going to win a
championship ever again or ever.
Really.
I think that's what he said.
And then he took the curse off,
I believe.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
These people.
But it didn't occur as harden because
took his uh,
then credited from it.
I believe his wife movement,
I don't know if it was like cooking,
like I got to eat whatever,
starting food up.
I'm eating right now.
You're like,
when you're,
when you're killing it and like that was
a little bees move so nobody lifted.
It looks like you lift at sea lifts.
Curse and james harden.
Chris,
multiple people on twitter.
It's a thing you don't want.
That's when it happened.
I took,
I texted you and I was like,
oh see when the thing was when,
when a guy like that says he's cursing
and that's what [inaudible] all about.
It gets in your head.
That's right.
Mind fucks you.
What does he dress like?
Dress like that?
Yes.
He just like a chick with a,
like an old lady's hat and a dress on.
He's definitely had a wide variety of
outfits.
Fascinating.
He wants to do a podcast.
Oh,
you should do it.
It does.
God,
he's going to come in.
Base.
Guys are going to come down here.
Yep.
We're gonna.
Keep popping feet and face photo.
Send them in feet and face.
Yeah.
That's what he wants.
One of his themes.
Yeah.
He wants girls feet and their face
showed me your face too.
I'll be going to show your feet.
Yeah,
because it can't be busted.
Well like.
Yeah.
What if you have a nice fee and your
face is on the other thing.
Yeah.
The other way around.
You keep your socks on if you're hot,
funky feet.
Right?
No one wants to see that shit.
He is a serious character though.
Yeah man.
He's an interesting guy.
Interesting guy.
He's probably the first guy to come with
the public curse.
Like who?
Who else?
Who's publicly curse people,
I dunno.
And it's worked.
That's what's crazy is this is bold.
Just to have that in your arsenal of I'm
saying of of insults or beef,
like to be the first like if somebody
was.
Somebody said like,
joe,
this dude was talking shit about you and
you're like,
that's fine.
I just cursed that motherfucker.
Like that in and of itself is just
terrifying.
Yeah.
Especially if it works.
Confident move,
man.
I want to say that the base,
god's curse is gone from kevin doran
under are free now to win future games.
You can't win hating.
Luckily signs all this,
his tweets,
lil b,
he signs.
Okay,
so he took that off awhile ago.
I didn't realize it was that.
I remember when it happened.
I was like,
ooh,
that's not good.
All right,
let's wrap this up.
Tommy bonds your mom's house podcast.
Tom [inaudible] dot com touring all of
the world.
Don't sleep on the tickets because
they're going fast.
It's fun today,
man.
Thanks my pledge,
brother.
Let's wrap this up and accuse me.
Oh,
alright.
Well see you guys next week.
Lots.
Lots more podcasts coming.
See ya.
Bye.